ALAN ARCHULETA AT KINS FACE
BACKER PORGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CORTEZ THREE DALLY
DODD TORONTO EGGMAN GLAZER
GONZALEZ GROVE HURTS BERG WAY
SO HER TADO. JONES CAN LONGER
LAYERED LLEVA THE MON MCGUIRE
MELINDA'S MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN A
CELLO BOW PAM FORTUNE TINO
RALPH RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER
WELL.
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND
IN THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL
BE LED IN PRAYER THIS AFTERNOON
BY SENATOR AIKMAN AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WILL BE
LED IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. BY SENATOR LAYERED.
SENATOR AIKMAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTERS PLEASE JOIN ME.
ONCE UPON A TIME IN A REMOTE
UNFRIENDLY VILLAGE BY A
MOUNTAIN THERE LIVED AN OLD
WOMAN WHO'S HAD IT SEEMS
STRANGE TO HER NEIGHBORS OFTEN
THEY WOULD SEE HER WANDERING ON
THE MOUNTAINSIDE WHICH LOOKED
BLEAK AND BARREN. DESPITE
THERE'S PARENTS ADMIN NATIONS
THE CHILDREN OF THE VILLAGE
SOMETIMES FALL THE OLD WOMAN
ASKING HER WHAT SHE WAS DOING.
SHE WOULD TELL THEM. I AM
CHANGING THE FACE OF THE
MOUNTAIN. MANY YEARS LATER ONE
ONE GROWN CHILD RETURN TO SHOW
HER FAMILY THE HARSH
ENVIRONMENT EVER USED. SHE WAS
SURPRISED TO SEE THE
MOUNTAINSIDE A BLAZE WITH
COLORFUL FLOWERS AND SHADY FOR
LUNCH. SHE ASKED THE VILLAGERS
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE BLEAK AND
BARREN MOUNTAINSIDE OF HER
CHILDHOOD. PLAQUE REMEMBER
LITTLE WOMAN WANDERING AROUND
THE MOUNTAINSIDE. IT WAS SHE
WHO PLANTED ALL THE SEEDS AND
NOW THEY ARE BEARING FRUIT. AND
THEN SHE UNDERSTOOD THE MEANING
OF THE WORD CHANGING THE FACE
OF THE MOUNTAIN. GRACIOUS LORD
WE ASK FOR YOUR CONTINUED
BLESSINGS AND ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THIS LEGISLATURE. AS THEY
WORK TO CHANGE THE FACE OF THE
MOUNTAIN. ME THE PERSEVERE WITH
HOPE AND COURAGE AS THEY
TRANSFORM POSSIBILITIES. INTO
REALITIES WE ASK THIS IN YOUR
NAME AMEN. YEAH. MESSAGES FROM
THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE SENATE JOURNALS
FOR THE WEEK OF MAY SEVENTEENTH
THROUGH MAY TWENTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL BE APPROVED AS
CORRECTED BY THE MINUTE CLERK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION PURSUANT TO
JOINT RULE THIRTY THREE POINT
ONE JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE AND
SIXTY TWO WILL BE SUSPENDED TO
ALLOW THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE
TO MEET AND REPORT. AB ONE OH
FOUR DEADLINE AFTER THE
DEADLINES THIS REQUEST HAS BEEN
APPROVED BY THE RULES COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
SECOND READING FILE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
SEVEN SEVEN SENATE BILL TO
SENATE BILL FOUR FOURTEEN.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY THE SECOND READING
FILE WILL BE DEEMED RED WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FOLLOWED WAS ONE
FORTY TWO AND ONE FORTY THREE
WILL START WITH FALLON ONE
FORTY TWO SENATOR BATES. CAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT BY
LETTING ONE FORTY TWO IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF CHRISTOPHER
DOWNEY FOR REAPPOINTMENT AND
DRAKE DILLARD AND JACQUELYN
JACKSON FOR APPOINTMENT TO THE
COMMISSION ON DISABILITY
ACCESS. MR DOWNEY ND MISS
JACKSON SERVICE REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE DISABILITY COMMUNITY. MR
DILLARD IS A REPRESENTATIVE OF
THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY THESE
APPOINTEES WERE APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MAY
NINETEENTH. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS.
EIGHT HI BACKER. HI FORGES HI
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T. FOR
TESTING. HI DALLY HI TODD. FIVE
TORONTO HI ADNAN. THIS IS THE
LASER. YEAH FIVE DOLLARS HI
GROSS. HI HERTZBERG FIVE WEST
SO I HER TADO I JONES. I CAN
LONGER HI LAYERED HI LLEVA. HI
LYNN MON. HI MCGUIRE I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN I A TELEPHONE. HI PAM
HI PORTS AND TINA HI ROTH.
RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN.
AMBERG HI WHAT KIND OF SKI FIVE
WINNER I WILL I WILL REMOVE THE
CULT MEMBERS REMOVED THE FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY THREE SENATOR
BATES THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FORTY
THREE OF THE CONFIRMATION OF
REBECCA EISEN. OINTMENT TO THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION
AND DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION.
MISS ISON IS CURRENTLY RETIRED
SHE PREVIOUSLY SERVED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
TRUSTEE AND WAS A PARTNER AT
THE LAW FIRM MORGAN LEWIS SHE
WAS APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON MAY NINETEENTH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOAT THANK YOU SENATOR BATES
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. BATES HI BACKER. I FORTUS
HI BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I
COURTESY HI DALLY I DON. HI
THERE ALSO I EGGMAN HI GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. I
HURTS BERG I WISH SO HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LIVE IN I LIVE ALONE
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S HI MAN I
NEWMAN I NELSON. BY A SHOW OF
BOGUE HI PAN I PRESENT YOU KNOW.
HI ROB I. RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN. AMBERG HI WHAT KIND OF
SKI I WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. AT
KINS. STERN FIVE THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO SENATE THIRD READING
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH
PALATABLE ONE FIFTY TWO SENATOR
HUESO SENATOR WAY SO ARE YOU
PREPARED. BUT OKAY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO ENERGY
SENDIRI SO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AS
P. SEVEN FIVE SIX THIS BILL
WILL EXPAND THE INCOME
ELIGIBILITY FOR LOW INCOME
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM- THE ELECTRICITY ENERGY
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM IS ONE OF
THE STATE'S LONGEST TENDER.
SPENDING ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY PROGRAM SORRY
ABOUT THAT THIS BILL WOULD
EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY TO LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. WHOSE INCOME
FALLS JUST ABOVE THE CURRENT
LIMIT OF TWO HUNDRED SEVEN
FEDERAL POP PROPER LEVEL. TO
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS AT OR BELOW
2050% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF
POLICY COMMITTEE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SEND OUR WAY SO MEMBERS IN
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. NEVER MIND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS. BAYTEX. BACKER HI PORGES.
HI BRADFORD HI BY ADAM HI
CORTEZ C. I. DALLY. I DON. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER.
FIVE DOLLARS I GROWTH HI HURTS
BERG. I WAS SO. I HER TADO HI
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED. I
LLEVA I LIVE ALONE I REQUIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. I CAN
HI PORTS AND TINA. HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN I
AM BERG HI LIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I
BATES. HI HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY THREE SENATOR LEMOND
BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR LEE MOANS AN ACT
RELATING TO SOLAR SOLAR ENERGY
SYSTEMS SENATOR RAMON THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP FOUR
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN WILL HOLD
SOLAR CONTRACT TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AS OTHER HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACTS ALTHOUGH
SOLAR IS OFTEN CONSIDERED A
HOME IMPROVEMENT THIS BILL
WOULD CLARIFY SOLAR CONSUMERS
HAVE THE SAME CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AS- ANY OTHER HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT THIS BILL
WILL ALSO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENCY TO THE CONSUMER
AND REQUIRE THE STILLS PERSON
TO DISCLOSE. THE CONTRACTORS
THEY ARE WORKING WITH SO THE
CONSUMER CAN MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I LOVE THE CENTER LAMONT
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
OF SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WITH ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS I BAIT. BACKER. FIVE FOR
JUST FIVE BRADFORD. I HAVE A I
COURTESY I DALLY. I DONT I
TORONTO HI ADNAN I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES FIVE GROVE.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER TADO
I JONES I CAN LONGER. I LAYERED
HI LLEVA I LOVE MON HI WIRE. I
MELINDA'S FIVE MEN HI FIVE
NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN. BUT SHOW
VOGUE HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I WILL.
HI PLEASE CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS. BAYTEX I. GROVE.
NIELSEN HI FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE- A LOT OF. I GROVE I.
HIGHS FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY EIGHT
SENATOR CABALLERO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. NO
SENATE BILL FIFTY NINE BY
SENATOR KABBADI AUTO AN ACT
RELATED TO CANNABIS CENTER
CAREER PATHS ON FILE VERY GOOD
PASS ON FILE WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE
SENATOR HUESO. HOUSE ON FILE
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY FOUR SENATOR PAN. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SORRY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE RESOLUTION THIRTY
TWO BY SENATOR PAN RELATIVE TO
ASIAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH.
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS PLEASE JOIN
ME IN CELEBRATING ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH. AS
CHAIR OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I
AM PROUD TO PRESENT S. R.
THIRTY TWO WHICH RECOGNIZES ME
AS A P. I HEARD EACH MONTH.
EACH MAY OUR COUNTRY CELEBRATES
THE DIVERSITY OF PEOPLES WHOSE
AND FAMILIES OF EMIGRATED FROM
ASIA AND THE PACIFIC ISLANDS TO
COME TO AMERICA. FOR
OPPORTUNITY AND FREEDOM. MAY
WAS INITIALLY CHOSEN TO
COMMEMORATE THE IMMIGRATION OF
THE FIRST JAPANESE IMMIGRANTS
IN THE UNITED UNITED STATES ON
MAY THIRD EIGHTEEN FORTY THREE.
AS WELL AS THE COMPLETION OF
THE TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD
WHICH IS BUILT WITH CHINESE
LABOR ON MAY TENTH. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE. TODAY NARLY SIX
POINT SEVEN MILLION ASIAN
AMERICANS CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
OVER HALF OF THE API'S IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IMMIGRANTS BOTH
OTHER API FAMILIES HAVE LIVED
IN AMERICA FOR GENERATIONS.
BECAUSE AMERICANS WE BRING A
DIVERSITY OF RICH CULTURAL
HERITAGE IS TO IMPROVE OUR
COUNTRY. THIS IS A TIME OF
CELEBRATION IN RECOGNITION OF
HER VERY COMMUNITIES. PART OF
THE CELEBRATION THE CONCERT
CALIFORNIA ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
RECOGNIZES DISTINGUISHED ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEADERS AND
HONORED THEM WITH THE
EXCELLENCE AWARDS. THIS YEAR WE
ARE PROUD TO RECOGNIZE EIGHT
HONOREES WHO UP LIFTED THE
VOICES OF THE API COMMUNITIES
DURING A PARTICULARLY DIFFICULT
TIME. AND CONTINUE TO RICH OUR
HISTORY AND CULTURE THROUGH
THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS. AND WE DO
HAVE THEIR NAMES IN A BOOKLET
THAT'S OUTSIDE THE MANUAL OUT
HERE. FOR EXCELLENCE IN ARTS
AND ENTERTAINMENT WE HONOR
DANIEL DAE KIM ACTOR AND
PRODUCER FOR SPEAKING OUT AND
UP LIFTING H. I. VOICES. FOR
EXCELLENCE IN CIVIC ENGAGEMENT
WE ARE HONORED TO PROGRESSIVE
VIETNAMESE AMERICAN
ORGANIZATION OR PIVOT FOR
CIVICALLY ENGAGING AND
MOBILIZING THE VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITY. FOR EXCELLENCE IN
CIVIL RIGHTS WE HONOR CONNIE
ONE. COUCH CO FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR RECTOR OF
AAPI WOMEN LEAD FOR EMPOWERING
ATI WOMEN. FOR EXCELLENCE IN
HEALTH WE HONOR DR ERICA POND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
EPIDEMIOLOGIST AND DEPUTY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CENTER FOR
INFECTIOUS DISEASES AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. FOR STEPPING UP TO BE
OUR ACTING STATE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER DURING THIS PANDEMIC TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC HEALTH DURING
THIS DIFFICULT TIME. THIS YEAR
THE APL LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO PRESENT A
SPECIAL RECOGNITION TO THE
CREATORS OF STOP AT I HATE. IN
RESPONSE TO THE ALARMING
ESCALATION OF XENOPHOBIA AND
BIGOTRY RESULTING FROM THE COVE
IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC THESE
INDIVIDUALS LAUNCHED THE STOCK%
API EIGHT REPORTING CENTER ON
MARCH NINETEENTH TWENTY TWENTY.
THEIR DATA ONCE KEY DISCUSSIONS
IN CRITICAL CHANGES NEEDED TO
COMBAT HATE AGAINST THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITIES.
THE API LET'S SAY KAKISSIS
PROUD TO HONOR THE CREATORS OF
STOP AT I HATE. MANJOO SHOP
COOK CARNEY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF ASIAN PACIFIC PLANNING A
POLICY COUNCIL. SINCE YOU'RE
CHOI ECHO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE
ACTION. VINCENT PINE CO
DIRECTOR EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CHINESE FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION.
DR RUSSELL JONES PROFESSOR OF
ASIAN AMERICAN STUDIES AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY.
WANT TO THANK EACH OF OUR
HONOREES FOR ELEVATING ATI
VOICES AND INSISTING THAT OUR
COMMUNITY BE VISIBLE AND HURT
IN OUR COUNTRY. API HAVE MADE
MAJOR CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE AND NATION SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. EXAMPLES OF
SAUDIS CONTRIBUTIONS CAN BE
FOUND IN BAGS OUTSIDE THE
MANUAL OUT SO THIS IS WHAT THEY
ARE. FINDING OUTSIDE- EACH BAG
CONTAINS A WHISTLE FROM PLO
WHISTLE CAMPAIGN DOES A
POWERFUL SYMBOL SIGNIFYING THE-
FIGHT AGAINST ANTI ASIAN HATE.
AFTER REACHING OUT TO OUR LOCAL
API COMMITTEE MEMBERS WE ARE
ALSO ABLE TO COMPILE A SMALL
SAMPLE OF SWEET SNACKS THAT RE
FAVORITES AMONG AMONG SAMOAN
JAPANESE INDIAN AND VIETNAMESE
COMMUNITIES. DESCRIPTION HAVE
HOW EACH COMMUNITY CELEBRATES
AND ENJOYS THESE CANDIES CAN BE
FOUND IN THE COMPANY BOOKLET.
YOU WILL ALSO NOTICE THAT WE'VE
SNACK. THAT IS OFTEN MISTAKEN
AS PART OF ASIAN CULTURE. D.
FORTUNE COOKIE WHICH WAS
INVENTED HERE. IN CALIFORNIA
THERE'S SOME DEBATE ABOUT WHO
INVENTED IT THOUGH THE PROGRAM
ALSO PROVIDES A BRIEF HISTORY
OF THE FORTUNE COOKIE WHICH IS
CHRIST HOW THE FORTUNE COOKIES
CREATING CALIFORNIA BUT HAS
BEEN USED IN THE PAST THE MOCK
CHINESE AND EAST ASIAN CULTURES.
HOWEVER WE HAVE DONE MORE THAN
JUST THE LIVER AWFULLY CREDIBLE
SNACKS. THE API COMMUNITY WE'VE
BUILT RAILROADS LEVEES FARM
FIELDS CARE FOR THE SICK FED
THE HUNGRY CREATING NEW JOBS
TAUGHT IN U. SCOLDING
DIVERSITIES AND FOUGHT FOR
AMERICA. WE WILL BE RECOGNIZED
FOR WHO WE ARE. AMERICA IS
STRONGER THERE'S A STRONGER
BETTER COUNTRY BECAUSE OF ASIAN
AMERICANS NATIVE HAWAIIANS AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS SOMEWHAT
WE'VE CONTRIBUTED TO AMERICA.
WE ARE PROUD TO BE ASIANS
PACIFIC ISLANDERS AND WE ARE
PROUD TO CELEBRATE API HERITAGE
MONTH WITH YOU. PLEASE
CELEBRATE WITH US AND VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF S. R. THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
PAM SENATOR NIELSEN. NOT A
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
SENATOR BY RICE IS ONE OF THE
ORIGINAL FOUNDERS OF SOMETHING
CALLED THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN PUBLIC
AFFAIRS ASSOCIATION NOW TWENTY
YEARS. OLD SIX OF US GOT
TOGETHER IN A TINY ROOM AND
DECIDED THAT WE NEEDED TO HAVE
SOMETHING OF GREATER MAGNITUDE
TO EMPOWER AND ENCOURAGE.
STIMULATE AND HEALTH ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDERS TO SUCCEED IN
ALL MANNER AND WAGE. A POP WAS
AND FOUND ANOTHER THIRTY ONE
CHAPTERS ACROSS AMERICA OF THE
ASIAN PACIFIC AMERICAN PUBLIC
AFFAIRS MY WIFE MARYLAND. WHO
IS NEITHER ASIAN. BUT SHE IS A
NATIONAL VICE PRESIDENT OF A
POP UP. ON THIS WEDNESDAY NIGHT
THEY HAVE A BIG EVENT AT THE
INN RANCH IN BACK OF BILL I'LL
BRING IN PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER
THE COUNTRY THE VARIOUS THIRTY
ONE CHAPTERS. TO A POP THE KEY
HERE IT WAS WE WERE WANTING TO
SEE MORE. THE FIRST STEP OF
PAPA TO GET MORE ASIAN PACIFIC
TIME PACIFIC ISLANDERS IN
APPOINTED POSITIONS IN
GOVERNMENT. AND THAT
ORGANIZATION HAS SUCCEEDED
ADMIRABLY AT ALL LEVELS. THIS
IS A AND THERE ARE CERTAINLY
BEEN CELEBRATING THIS WEEK AS
WELL AS I SAY AT THE END LATCH
ON WEDNESDAY NIGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON SENATOR NEWMAN.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SANDERS I RISE TODAY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF SENATE SENATE
RESOLUTION THIRTY TWO
COMMEMORATING MAY AS ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
HERITAGE MONTHS IN CALIFORNIA
OUR NATION'S GREATEST STRENGTH
IS THE CHARACTER AND INTEGRITY
OF ITS PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF
RACE GENDER RELIGION OR
ETHNICITY AND CALIFORNIA
RIGHTLY AND PROUDLY CELEBRATES
THE RICHNESS OF THIS DIVERSITY.
IN THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
NEARLY 30% OF RESIDENTS
IDENTIFY AS API. AND IN MY
COMMUNITY IN MY DISTRICT AS
ACROSS THE STATE THIS COMMUNITY
ISNEITHER HOMOGENOUS NOR
MONOLITHIC EACH API GROUP
CONTRIBUTES A DISTINCT AND
VIBRANT CULTURE OF LANGUAGE
CUISINE TRADITION AND
GENERATIONAL PERSPECTIVE ON
BEHALF OF THIS DIVERSE EVEN
THAT STAND TOGETHER TO DEFEND
THE AMERICAN IDEALS OF JUSTICE
AND EQUALITY FROM THE
DISCRIMINATION CHINO PHOBIA AND
BIGOTRY THAT CAN THREATEN OUR
LOFTIEST BELIEVES CALIFORNIANS.
LET US ALL JOIN IN CELEBRATING
THE EXCEPTIONAL AND
INDISPUTABLY AMERICAN
NARRATIVES OF OUR API FRIENDS
FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORS BY
SUPPORTING SR THITY TWO THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT. I SALUTE
SENATOR PAN AND THE CARCASS FOR
THIS LIST OF PEOPLE. AND I
THOUGHT IT WAS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE SOMEBODY THAT'S NOT ON
THE LIST AND HAPPENS TO BE. A
CONSTITUENT IS TOMMY GORMAN WHO
IS ONE OF THE FIRST IF NOT THE
FIRST OF LOCAL COUNTY CLERK.
WHO IS ASIAN AMERICAN AND AS
THE NATIONAL NEWS HAS REPORTED
AT A PUBLIC MEETING OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS- JUST TIE
THINK LAST WEEK HE WAS
SUBJECTED TO AN ANTI ASIAN
SLOWER IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
CROWDED PUBLIC MEETING. AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IN THE
LIGHT OF WHAT WAS SAID IN
INTRODUCING THIS RESOLUTION.
THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT ARE
OUTSTANDING LEADERS AND THEY
SUBJECT SPORTS SUBJECT TO SOME
OF THIS DISCRIMINATION. THAT
GOES ON AND IT HAPPENED THAT
DAY AND I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ALL OF US TO CALL
IT OUT. NOT JUST VOTE FOR THIS
RESOLUTIONBUT SUPPORT THE ONE
OF THE OWNER REACHED IT IS
ACTUALLY COMPILING AND
DOCUMENTING AND HIGHLIGHTING.
AND RESPONDING TO THE HATE THAT
EXISTS SO IN THE NAME OF TOM
AND GONE I'M GONNA BE PROUD TO
VOTE FOR THIS RESOLUTION AND
ASK ALL MY COLLEAGUES TO DO IT
AS WELL THANK. YOU THANK YOU
SAID EARLIER SENATOR MAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HIGH RISE
AS A PROUD CO AUTHORED SR.
THIRTY TWO AND IS A MEMBER OF
THE A. K. LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
AUTHORING THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZING OUR COMMUNITY. S.
R. THIRTY TWO RECOGNIZES THE
MONTH OF MAY S. A. P. I.
HERITAGE MONTH. WHICH IS SO
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW TO
RECOGNIZE THIS AND THE VALUE
AND IMPORTANCE OF API HISTORY.
GIVEN ALL OF THE WELL
DOCUMENTED AND UBIQUITOUS HEY
AND HARDSHIP THAT OUR API
COMMUNITY. HASN'T HEARD OVER
THE PAST YEAR. NOW WE KNOW THAT
ANTI ASIAN DISCRIMINATION IS
NOT NEW AND GOES BACK TO THE
ORIGINS OF IMMIGRATION TO THIS
COUNTRY. BUT WHAT WE'RE FACING
RIGHT NOW IS SHOCKING AND
FRIGHTENING TO MANY OF US- AND
I THINK JUST THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE FEEL LIKE THEY CAN GO UP
TO ASIAN AMERICANS IN THE
STREET. IN THEIR PLACES OF WORK
AT THEIR HOMES. AND EVEN IF NOT
NECESSARILY COMMIT VIOLENT ACTS
WHICH WE'RE SEEING A LOT OF-
JUST INVADE PEOPLE'S SENSE OF
SAFETY AND SECURITY- I THINK
ALLOWS IT BECAUSE IT'S TOO MANY
OF US TO FEEL FRIGHTENED TO
FEEL UNWELCOME IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND WE CANNOT ALLOW THIS TO
HAPPEN. WE ALL KNOW THE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED STATES
ARE BEAUTIFUL BECAUSE OF OUR
DIVERSITY AND THAT IS IN PART
BECAUSE OF THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
ASIANS. AND PACIFIC ISLANDERS
LIKE MY PARENTS WHO CAME. OUT
TO HEAR FROM KOREA IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE. MY PARENTS GREW UP
IN THE KOREAN WAR AND ITS
AFTERMATH AT A TIME WHEN FOOD
WAS SCARCE. AND THE ECONOMY WAS
STRUGGLING AND THE REASON THEY
LOVE SPAM AND TRIED TO RAISE ME
AND MY BROTHER LOVE SPAM
SOMETHING THAT DID NOT STICK.
WAS BECAUSE OF THE GENEROSITY
OF THE EYES AND IF YOU'RE
WONDERING WHY SPAM IS SO
POPULAR IN KOREA AND MANY ASIAN
COUNTRIES. IT'S BECAUSE OF
THAT. AND I THINK WE ARE THE
EPITOME OF THE AMERICAN DREAM A
STORY TAT'S BEEN SHARED BY
MILLIONS OF OTHER ATI
IMMIGRANTS OVER THE PAST YEARS
AND GENERATIONS. WE'VE MADE
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTIONS TO THIS
COUNTRY. AS WE ALL KNOW AND
THIS HAS BEEN A WELCOME HOME
FOR CALIFORNIANS OF API DISSENT
OVER THE PAST FEC. VACATES WITH
SIXTY ONE THREE MILLION EIGHT.
LIVE HERE. A NUMBER THAT WILL
GROW OVER TIME. WE HAVE. TO
CONDEMN THIS VIOLENCE AND
WELCOME ASIAN AMERICANS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ON- THE CENTER
WHERE DISSIPATED. IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO CONDEMN HATE TO
CONDEMN AND STAND UP AGAINST
THISTYPE OF BUILDING THAT
WE'RE SEEING. CALIFORNIA IS ONE
OF THE PLACES THE API'S CALL
HOME. WHERE WE FEEL COMFORTABLE
IF WE DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
HERE WHERE CAN WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE IN UNITED STATES.
SO I APPRECIATE THIS
RESOLUTION. THE RECOGNITION OF
OUR DIVERSE COMMUNITIES WITH
CELEBRATIONS LIKE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER HERITAGE
MONTH. AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR MEN CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
STAND SURE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY
TWO AND AS STATED- MAY WAS
FIRST RECOGNIZED AS ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER- MONTH TO THE
ARRIVAL OF THE FIRST JAPANESE
AMERICAN OR JAPANESE IN MAY OF
CERTAIN ON THE SEVENTH EIGHTEEN
FORTY THREE. AND IT WAS
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED- IN
NINETEEN NINETY TWO AS OFFICIAL
MONTH FOR ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER HERITAGE MONTH AS
STATED CALIFORNIA'S THE HOME OF
OVER SIX MILLION ASIANS WHO
HAVE CONTRIBUTED TO OUR SOCIETY
BOTH IN CULTURAL SOCIAL AND
ECONOMIC ADVANCES IN AREAS OF
BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION
SCIENCE GOVERNMENT MEDICINE.
SPORTS AND ENTERTAINMENT AND
SOME OF THE NOTE AP OCT THAT
MAKES CONTRIBUTIONS ARE THE
TWENTY THOUSAND CHINESE WORKERS
PARTICIPATED IN THE
TRANSCONTINENTAL RAILROAD LARRY
ADDING ON THE FILIPINO. LABOR
LEADER WHO HELPED FORM- UFCW
WITH CESAR CHAVEZ AND LET. THE
GREAT STRIKE IN DELANO. THE
COACH I'M CULTURE YEAH. THE
JAPANESE ARMY AND NATO OF SAN
PEDRO KNOWN FOR HER POLITICAL
ACTIVISM AND ADVOCATED AND
FOUGHT ON THE FRONTLINES FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS OF ALL PEOPLE. AND
AS THE FOUNDER OF AMERICAN I
MEAN ASIAN AMERICANS FOR ACTION
JURY SOUGHT TO BUILD A MORE
POLITICAL ASIAN AMERICAN
MOVEMENT THAT WOULD LEND ITSELF
TO THE STRUGGLES OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. JURY ALSO MET HER
GOAL OF IT EVENTUALLY JOINING
FORCES WITH MALCOLM ACTS TO
WORK TOWARD RACIAL JUSTICE AND
HUMANRIGHTS. AS WE CELEBRATE
THIS MONTH IN THE CONSONANTS
AND CONTRIBUTIONS OF THE API
COMMUNITY. WE SHOULD ALSO
CONTINUE TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THE HARMFUL DISCRIMINATION AND-
PHYSICAL THREATS OR VIOLENCE
INFLICTED UPON THEM. HATE
VIOLENCE IS A PUBLIC SAFETY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE ALL
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE CONCERNED
WITH NOT JUST THOSE THAT FIND
THEMSELVES THE VICTIMS OF IT.
AS CALIFORNIANS MARCH ST
DIVERSITY IS OUR BEACON OF
PRIDE AND WE MUST BE WILLING TO
DO EVERYTHING WITHIN OUR POWER
TO STAND WITH THOSE THREATENED
BY THIS AND PROMOTE RACIAL
HARMONY AND LET US REMAIN
MINDFUL AND CELEBRATE AND
UPLIFT A. A. R. I. A. P. I.
FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS AND WITH
THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR
S. R. THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD CENTRE TORONTO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. R. AS
CHAIR OF THE LATINO CAUCUS AND
THE SENATOR REPRESENTING. A
VERY DIVERSE AREA INCLUDING
THAI TOWN KOREATOWN HISTORIC
FILIPINO TOWN CHINATOWN AND-
LITTLE TOKYO AND LITTLE
BANGLADESH. IS MY HONOR TO RISE
IN SUPPORT OF SR THIRTY TWO.
THE API COMMUNITY IN THE U. S.
IS FRAUGHT WITH DISCRIMINATION
AND IN HUMANE TREATMENT. WHEN
THE CHINESE EXCLUSION ACT. TO
THE INTERNMENT OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS DURING WORLD WAR TWO.
TO THE YET WE HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY EXAMPLES LIKE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE FILIPINO
LEADERS THAT SPURRED THE DELANO
GRAPE STRIKE AND LED TO THE
FORMATION OF THE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION. THE RESILIENCY
OF THE API COMMUNITY DESERVES
TO BE CELEBRATED. WE ARE AFTER
ALL THE BENEFICIARY STATE OF
THIRTY ALMOST 32% OF OUR
NATION'S ASIAN OWNED BUSINESSES
WE MUST CHANGE THE HATE
NARRATIVE THAT IS GOING ON IN
THIS COUNTRY. I'LL LEAVE YOU
WITH THE STORY OF RALPH LASSELL
AN EXAMPLE OF THE SOLIDARITY
BETWEEN THE API AND LATINO
COMMUNITIES HE WAS A TEENAGER.
I WATCHED IN HORROR AS ALL OF
HIS JAPANESE AMERICAN FRIENDS
WERE SENT TO INTERNMENT CAMPS
DURING WORLD WAR TWO. SO HE
BECAME THE ONLY KNOWN PERSON OF
NON JAPANESE ANCESTRY. WHO
VOLUNTEERED TO LIVE IN AN
INTERNMENT CAMP. WHAT SOME SAW
AS A YEARS LONG RUSSE OR PROOF
THAT HE SYMPATHIZED WITH THE
ENEMY HE SAW AS AN ACT OF
SOLIDARITY HE HAD EXPERIENCED
RACISM RACISM IN HIS OWN SHORT
LIFE. FREE TOOK THIS PERSONAL
DECISION AND STAYED IN THE
INTERNMENT CAMP FOR TWO YEARS
WITH HIS FRIENDS A PRISONER BY
CHOICE ACTING FROM HIS
CONSCIOUS. AS CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I SAY LET US ALL
BE MORE LIKE RALPH LAWSON THANK
YOU SENATOR PAN AND THE API
LEGISLATIVE CONQUER POCKETS FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAWS- SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
THIRTY TWO- TO PROCLAIM THE
MONTH OF MAY AS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER AMERICAN HERITAGE
MONTH. AS WE CELEBRATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR API
COMMUNITIES TO CALIFORNIA- WE
AS JEWS REFLECT ON THE
INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF OUR TWO
COMMUNITIES AND COMMEMORATE OUR
LONG LINEAGES OF- IN TERMS OF
FIGHTING ADVERSITY- AND
RESILIENCY. BUT WE REMEMBER THE
ROLE OF ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
DURING THE HOLOCAUST WHEN CHINA
WAS ONE OF THE ONLY COUNTRIES
THAT DID NOT RESTRICT
IMMIGRATION. WELCOMING MORE
THAN TWENTY THOUSAND JEWS WHO
WERE PLAYING EASTERN EUROPE AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE HOLOCAUST.
CAN JUICE. BECAME INVOLVED IN
FIGHTING JAPANESE INTERNMENT
THE UNITED STATES. RECOGNIZING
THE SIMILARITIES BETWEEN CRIMES
AGAINST OUR TWO PEOPLE. ROBERT
IRVING RECORD OF SAN
FRANCISCO'S TEMPLE EMANUEL WAS
A FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FAIR PLAY
COMMITTEE- AND OTHER PRODUCTS
AND HE AND OTHER PROMINENT JEWS
WERE INVOLVED. IN THIS FIGHT.
RIGHT AFTER THE WAR THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN CITIZENS
LEAGUE JOINED A COALITION WITH
LEADING JEWISH ORGANIZATIONS.
TO BUILD INTERRACIAL COALITIONS
AND WORK TO REPEAL I'M JUST
LAND LAWS AND NATURALIZATION
BOUNDS. IN RECENT YEARS OUR TWO
COMMUNITIES HAVE EXPERIENCED A
SIMILARLY SHARP UPTICK IN HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE. SERVICES
OUR HISTORY DEMONSTRATES THE
NECESSITY OF STANDING TOGETHER
WE HAVE PROUDLY AND CONTINUE TO
PROUDLY ADDRESS. THESE
CHALLENGES TOGETHER IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND BEYOND. THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY PROUDLY
CELEBRATES- API HERDERS MONTH.
ON BOTH OUR KNOWLEDGE OUR
SHARED EXPERIENCES COMMUNITIES
UNDER EXPRESS OUR MUTUAL.
SUPPORT YOUR JOB- THANK YOU
SENATOR WE SAID AIKMAN. VERY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AT MANTA PROVIDENCE-
I COULD RISE AS THE SENATOR
FROM STOCKTON WITH A STRONG
HISTORY OF A API- INFLUENCE IN
OUR CITY. WE HAVE A WHEN THE
OLDEST CHINESE RESTAURANTS IN-
IN THE STATE UNLOCKS SAM'S BEEN
WELL OVER A HUNDRED YEARS OLD.
THE HOME OF LARRY AT HOME ONE
OF THE- FOUNDERS OF THE
FARMWORKER MOVEMENT. ORGANIZED
OUT OF OUT OF STOCKTON- SOME OF
THE FAMOUS AUTHORS COME FROM
STOCKTON WE KNOW WE ARE THE
OLDEST SIKH TEMPLE IN THE
UNITED STATES IS IN STOCKTON.
AND WE KNOW ONE OF THE MASS
FIRST MASS SHOOTINGS OF
SOUTHEAST ASIAN CHILDREN ON
SCHOOL GROUNDS WAS IN STOCKTON
AND JUST LAST WEEK WE LAID TO
REST OFFICER JIMMY IN FROM THE
CAMBODIAN COMMUNITY. OF
STOCKTON WE HAVE A LARGE A
LARGE AND LONG AND VARIED
HISTORY OF API HERITAGE BUT
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE LBGT
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S. R.
THIRTY TWO. AS WE HONOR THE
ASIAN OR PACIFIC ISLANDER
HERITAGE MONTH EXCEPT THE
HIGHLIGHT JUST A FEW OF THE
INCREDIBLE A. P. I. L. G. B. T.
CHAMPIONS. TOOK TO CRY THE
JAPANESE AMERICAN HAS BEEN A
DIFFERENT TIER OF ADVANCING THE
RIGHTS AND VISIBILITY OF API
AND THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY
CENTERS. MEGAN YEARS ABOUT THE
USS ENTERPRISE ENTERPRISE IN
USING STORIES OFHIS OWN
CHILDHOOD IN THE JAPANESE CAMPS
TO EDUCATE GENERAL GENERATIONS
OF AMERICANS. TO THE DANGER OF
OTHER RISING. UNIVERSE ABILITY
TRANS ACT AND- WENT FROM TO
FRAN TO NEW YORK WITH A PASSION
FOR MODELING. AND WOULD GO ON
TO BE ONE OF THE FIRST TRANS
MODELS. TO APPEAR ON THE FRONT
COVER OF THE NUMEROUS FASHION
MAGAZINES. AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST. MARKET SHOW A CLEAR
KOREAN AMERICAN ACTRESS
COMEDIAN AUTHOR MUSICIAN AND
ACTIVIST ONE OF THE FEW QUEER
FEMALE ASIAN AMERICANS TO DO
SO. SHE HAS LONG BEEN A LONG
TIME ADVOCATE AND VOCAL
ACTIVIST FOR ANTI RACISM AND
ANTI BULLING ADVOCATING FOR THE
HOMELESS AND LGBT Q. RIGHTS.
THESE ARE BUT A FEW OF THE
INCREDIBLE ASIAN AMERICANS WHO
HAVE USED THEIR INTERSECTION
MALADY. AS A TOOL TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THE API
COMMUNITY HAS VALUE. HAS
STRENGTH. AND THIS AND IS
SINCERE IN ITS NEED TO BE
WHEREVER DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE. FOR THESE REASONS I
JOINED MY PEERS AND
RESPECTIVELY. TO YOU TO VOTE ON
SR THIRTY TWO. THANK YOU CENTER
AIKMAN MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR PAN
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I FIRST I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF MY GOOD FRIENDS.
WHO HAVE SPOKEN. AND THE
SOLIDARITY BETWEEN THE API
COMMUNITY AND MANY OTHER
COMMUTE MAY THE COMMUNITIES
THAT YOU REPRESENT- THE API
CONFUSING IS INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
COMMUNITY- AND SACKED- WE HAVE.
MEMBERS TO- AND- WHICH SPANNED
THE SOCIOECONOMIC SPECTRUM- WE
FACE A- VARIETY OF. DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCES COMING FROM
DIFFERENT PLACES AND HAVE
DIFFERENT EXPERIENCES HERE.
HOWEVER WE ARE TOGETHER AND-
AND COMMONALITY- AND- AND UNITY
AS WE FIGHT TO BE CHERYL
EVERYONE HERE IN AMERICA HAS
EQUAL RIGHTS AND TO PROCLAIM
THAT WE ARE AMERICANS. TOO
OFTEN THE ROOF CONSIDERED
FEDERAL FOREIGNER. WE ARE
AMERICANS WERE PROUD TO BE PART
OF THIS COUNTRY TO BE MEMBERS
OF THIS COUNTRY TO CONTRIBUTE
TO THIS COUNTRY. AND SO EVEN AS
SO WE ARE- FACING CODED WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO LATER IN
THIS YEAR BE ABLE TO CELEBRATE.
TOGETHER AND WITH THAT HEY
STRICTLY ASPIRIN I VOTE FOR SR
THIRTY TWO AGAIN THANK I THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR WONDERFUL
WORDS O SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. THOSE
ZERO THREAT SOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX.
SENATOR ATKINS. SENATOR SENATOR
RAZA SORRY ABOUT THAT M.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
DORADO AND AFTER LEADING TO
EMPLOYMENT CENTER DRAWS SO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT S. B.
SIXTY TWO MAKES CLEAR THAT A
BUSINESS CONTRACTING TO HAVE
GARMENTS MADE IS LIABLE FOR
UNPAID WAGES TO THE SKILLED
WORKERS WHO MAKE THOSE GARMENTS
REGARDLESS OF HOW MANY LAYERS
OF CONTRACTING THAT COMPANY MAY
USE. SINCE THE ORIGINAL GARMENT
WORKER PROTECTION ACT WAS
PASSED WE HAVE IDENTIFIED TWO
UNDERLYING CAUSES OF WAGE
THEFT. THAT HAVE CAUSE
CALIFORNIA TO FALL BEHIND IN
THE WORLD. LEAVING TAXPAYERS TO
SUBSIDIZE PERVASIVE
EXPLOITATION FIRST FASHION
BRANDS CREATE POVERTY WAGES TO
THE UNREALISTIC PRICING OF
GARMENT ORDERS AND YET THEY
HAVE NO LEGAL LIABILITY. AND
THE ARCHAIC SYSTEM OF PAIN BY
PIECE RATE. KEEPS MINIMUM WAGE
ALWAYS OUT OF THE REACH FOR
THESE WORKERS ONE HUNDRED FORTY
FASHION INDUSTRY BUSINESSES
MOSTLY WOMEN LED SMALL
BUSINESSES. ARE LEADING THE
CHARGE FOR ETHICAL WORKPLACE
AND SUSTAINABILITY STANDARDS IN
THE GARMENT INDUSTRY.
DISRUPTIONS TO THE GLOBAL CHAIN
FROM THIS PANDEMIC CAT
MOTIVATED COMPANIES TO SET UP
SHOP IN LOS ANGELES FOR BENEFIT
OF THE SKILLED LABOR. BRANSON
REALIZE THE ADVANTAGE OF A
STRONG DOMESTIC MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY IN REDUCING RISKS AND
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH INVENTORY
AS THE LARGEST INDUSTRY OF ITS
KIND IN THE U. S. THE APPAREL
MANUFACTURING INDUSTRY PRODUCES
FOUR POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL ANNUAL OUTPUT
FIST IN LOS ANGELES ALONE.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THESE WOMEN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS MANY OF WHOM
MAY THE COUNTRY'S MASK FOR TWO
CENTS A PIECE. FIFTY SIXTY TWO
IS THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS PRIORITY BILL.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUSSELL MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR ATKINS. PRESIDENT THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HI RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
TWO. THIS I REALLY A PERSONAL
ISSUE FOR ME AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW YOU'VE HEARD ME TELL ABOUT
MY MOTHER WHO WAS A SEAMSTRESS
AND SHE WAS A REALL GOOD ONE I
MIGHT ADD. I WILL NEVER FORGET
WATCHING MY MOM NIGHT AFTER
NIGHT DOING HER FIGURES. WHICH
IS WHAT SHE CALLED IT WHEN SHE
WOULD TALLY UP HER NUMBERS TO
DETERMINE IF SHE HAD MADE
PRODUCTION I KNEW THOSE
TECHNICAL TERMS AT A VERY YOUNG
AGE. LIKE MANY GARMENT WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA MOST OF WHOM ARE
WOMEN SHE WORKED PIECEMEAL. SO
IN ORDER TO FIGURE OUT HOW MUCH
MONEY YOUR FAMILY WOULD HAVE AT
THE END OF THE WEEK FOR FOOD OR
RENT EXPENSES. SHE WOULD HAVE
TO GRAB A PENCIL AND PAPER AND
DO HER FIGURES. I ACTUALLY
JOINED MY MOM AT THE FACTORY
ONE SUMMER WHILE I WAS HOME
FROM COLLEGE IT WAS ONE OF THE
HARDEST JOBS I'VE EVER HAD. BUT
I KNEW I'D BE GOING BACK TO
SCHOOL COME FALL. MY MOM DID
NOT HAVE THAT SAME RELIEF. DAY
AFTER DAY YEAR AFTER YEAR SHE
WOULD GO TO THE FACTORY. TO A
VERY DEMANDING JOB OR SHE MADE
VERY LITTLE MONEY. AS SHE GOT
OLDER AND SLOW DOWN THE FIGURES
YET ADD UP AT THE KITCHEN TABLE
GOT SMALLER AND SMALLER. THAT
WAS IN THE NINETEEN EIGHTIES.
THIRTY YEARS LATER NOT MUCH HAS
CHANGED. WOMEN ARE STILL
RUNNING DOWN THE CLOCK TO TURN
OUT AS MUCH PRODUCT AS POSSIBLE
SHOWING UP WHEN SICK SKIPPING
BREAKS. IN AN ATTEMPT TO PIECE
TOGETHER ENOUGH TO MAKE ENDS
MEET. WE NEED TO ASK OURSELVES
IS THAT RIGHT. THIS ISN'T ABOUT
HURTING BUSINESSES AFTER THE
CHALLENGES MANY OF THEM FACE
LAST YEAR WE HAVE TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE STABLE TOO BUT TO
MANY CORPORATIONS ARE
SUCCESSFULLY- SUCCEEDING AS
THEY STAND ON THE STOOP
EXHAUSTED AND UNDERPAID
SHOULDERS OF THEIR WORKERS. AND
ETHICAL EMPLOYERS ARE BEING
PUNISHED BY UNFAIR COMPETITION
I ASK AGAIN IS THAT RIGHT. IT'S
TIME TO STAND UP FOR THESE
WORKERS ESPECIALLY AFTER AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES SAID
THEY HELPED GET US THROUGH THE
PANDEMIC BY MAKING PP MASK AND
HOSPITAL GOWNS. AND WE HAVE TO
PROTECT RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES
AS WELL. I THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM LOS ANGELES FOR HER
CONTINUED DEDICATION TO THIS
ISSUE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR EYES OUT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND OUR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEN SENATOR
ALSO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I-
RESPECTFULLY ASK RELIABLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS OPEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BY
FAITH NO BACKER. HI FORGES NO
BRADFORD HI COME BY OTHER FIVE
COURTESY. HI DALLY NO DODD HI
THERE ALSO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JONES NO CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN.
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A SHOW
BOTH NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. I
HI RUBIO I SKINNER I STIR I AM
BERG I LIKE HOW SKI HI WE- I
WILL KNOW PLEASE CALL THE
OPTIMUM. GLAZER HER TADO. MAN
I'D HIDE. PRICE TWENTY NINE
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEMS ONE SIXTY FIVE SENATOR
SKINNER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO HOUSING CENTERS CAN- THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP
EIGHT EXTENDS A BILL THAT THIS
HOUSE PASSED AND WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
HOUSING CRISIS ACT. AND THAT
BILL'S PURPOSE WAS TO GIVE
CERTAINTY TO HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT PLAYED BY THE RULES
SPECIFICALLY DID HELP TO. GIVE
TIME CERTAINTY ON THE
PROCESSING OF A PERMIT AND
INSURING THAT THE RULES WERE
NOT CHANGED MIDSTREAM FOR
HOUSING PROJECTS THAT MET ALL
EXISTING LOCAL ZONING AND OTHER
RULES SO IT DID NOT CREATE ANY
EXCEPTIONS OR- CHANGER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RULES IT SAID IF
YOUR PROJECT AT THE POINT THAT
YOU SUBMIT THE APPLICATION.
MEETS THE LOCAL RULES THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE A TIME CERTAINTY FOR
THE PROCESSING OF THE PROJECT
AND THE RULES WOULDN'T CHANGE
WHILE YOU WHILE THE PERMIT WAS
BEING- THAT IT. NOW DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC THE FULL BENEFITS OF
SB THREE THIRTY HAVE YET TO BE
REALIZED SO S. B. EIGHT THE
BILL BEFORE YOU NOW JUST
EXTENDS THE SUNSET AND GIVES IT
FIVE MORE YEARS. AND IT ALSO-
GET CONCERNED IT CONTAINS THE
SAME ANTI DEMOLITION PRESS
PROTECTIONS AND DISPLACEMENT
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE IN THE
ORIGINAL BILL AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C. AND
HEARING THAT MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS. FIVE BASE.
NO BACKER HI FOR JUST. BRADFORD
BYE BYE YELLOW HI CORTEZ HE- I
DALLY. DODD HI- ALSO I EGGMAN I
GLAZER. NO GUNS ALLAH'S HIGH
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO I JONES. CAN LONGER.
I LAYERED. LLEVA HI THE MON. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NELSON. A SHOW OF BOTH
HI PAM I FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH.
I RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN.
AMBERG ALL RIGHT HI WE
CALLOUSLY. FIVE WINNER HI WELK.
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS DALLY. GROVE JONES.
WHERE'D I MELINDA'S. NIELSEN
STERN. WELL HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
TOO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR BRADFORD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD AN ACT
RELATING TO INSURANCE SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AS V. SIX FIVE FIVE
THE STREET FOR MEASURED SIMPLY
LOWERS THE THRESHOLD FROM A
HUNDRED MILLION TO. SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION AS IT RELATES TO
INSURANCE COMPANIES GOVERNING
BOARD AND SUPPLIER DIVERSITY
DATA THE CARD APPLIES REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS TO INCLUDE RIGS
POURING INSURANCE COMPANIES TO
PROVIDE AGOVERNING BOARD
DIVERSITY POLICY STATEMENT OR
MEASURABLE GOALS AND- IT.
DEFINES THE TERM DIVERSE
INVESTMENT MANAGERS IN THE CORN
PROGRAM THE SIMPLY BUILDS UPON
THE DATA- THAT WAS PULLED FROM
INSURERS AND USERS FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF MEASURABLES
TOWARD DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
CONCLUSION INVESTMENT PRACTICE
I SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I WAS
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE SIXTY NINE SENATOR MEN.
SENATOR MEN DID YOU WANT TO
PRESENT FOLLOWED A ONE SIXTY
NINE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL ONE SIXTH
SENATE BILL SIX FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR MEN AND ACTUALLY DID A
CHILD CUSTODY SENATOR. MY
APOLOGIES MADAM PRESIDENT FOR
THE DELAY THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SP SIX FIFTY FOUR WHICH
CREATES NE PROTECTIONS AND
EXTENDS EXISTING SAFEGUARDS FOR
CHILDREN IN FAMILY COURT.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BUILD US TWO
THINGS FIRST SB SIX FIFTY FOUR
PREVENTS A CHILD'S TESTIMONY
FROM BEING GIVEN IN THE PRESS
PRESENCE OF PARTY SEEKING
CUSTODY SUCH AS THE CHILD'S
PARENTS. UNLESS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY CHILDREN HAVE A RIGHT
TO BE HEARD IN CUSTODY AND THEY
SHOULD BE HEARD ENVIRONMENTS
THAT ARE SAFE AND ACCOMMODATING
SECONDLY SP SIX FIFTY FOUR
TAKES EXISTING SAFETY MEASURES
USED RELATED TO CHILD CUSTODY
DETERMINATION. AND EXTENDS THEM
TO UNSUPERVISED VISITATION
SPECIFICALLY INSURERS IT
ENSURES THAT JUDGES CONSIDER
HISTORIES OF ABUSE AND
ADDICTION WHEN MAKING CUSTODY
DETERMINATIONS. THIS IS A
CRITICAL MEASURE THAT WILL
ENSURE THE SAFETY AND THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING CHILDREN
OUR TOP PRIORITIES IN
CONTENTIOUS CUSTODY BATTLES.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU CENTERMAN
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR RUBIO. AND
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE
AND A PROUD CO AUTHOR TO THIS
BILL THIS IS SUCH AN IMPORTANT
BILL IN MY VIEW AS IT PERTAINS
TO OUR CHILDREN WHICH ARE MOST
VALUED AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THIS FEELS
IMPORTANT FOR TWO REASONS
NUMBER ONE. WE HAVE SEEN WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN SOMETIMES CHILDREN
GO BACK TO AN ABUSIVE HOUSEHOLD
AND HOW SOME CHILDREN DON'T
MAKE IT OUT. I WANT TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF PEAKY A FIVE YEAR OLD
BOY IN MY DISTRICT WHO WAS
MURDERED SUFFOCATED BY HIS
FATHER AFTER COURT. RELEASED
HIM TO HIS FATHER KNOWING THERE
HAD BEEN ABUSE IN THE HOME.
NUMBER TWO. I ALSO KNOW FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO SPEAK UP.
AGAINST SOMEONE THAT HAS HARM
TO YOU. IT'S ALREADY STRESSFUL
ENOUGH FOR AN ADULT AND I CAN
ONLY IMAGINE WHAT THAT MEANS
FOR A CHILD HAVING TO TESTIFY.
OR SPEAK AGAINST ONE OR BOTH
PARENTS. AND STILL TAKING THAT
TESTIMONY AWAY FROM THE PEOPLE
THAT HARM HIM IS VITAL FOR A
CHILD TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK. WITH
THE- CLARITY AND FEEL SAFE
ABOUT IT. IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT SO I APPRECIATE THAT
SENATOR FROM IRVINE FOR
BRINGING THIS MEASURE UP. WE
HAVE TO PROTECT OUR CHILDREN WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT IF WE EVER
ALLOW A CHILD TO GO BACK INTO
AN ABUSIVE HOME. THAT WE HAVE A
GOOD REASON FOR DOING SO IT HAS
TO BE IN WRITING AND THEY HAVE
TO JUSTIFY THAT THE RETURN OF
THE CHILD. I ALSO WANT TO SPEAK
FOR SAP A LITTLE BOY THAT
DIDN'T REALLY GET. VERY MUCH
COVERAGE AND I MY PERSONAL
OPINION DESERVES. TO BE
HIGHLIGHTED GABRIEL. FERNANDES
WHO ALSO WAS HARMED BY HIS
BIOLOGICAL MOTHER THE
STEPFATHER AND EVEN THOUGH THIS
DOES NOT FALL UNDER THIS LAW
THIS CHILD BY EIGHTEEN WAS SEEN
BY HIS TEACHERS ADMINISTRATORS
CHILD WELFARE WELFARE SERVICES
THEY ALL SAW THE BRUISES AND
EVERYTHING THIS LITTLE BOY WAS
HAVING TWIN DOOR AND WE FAILED
TO PROTECT HIM SO I THINK THIS
BILL IS WHAT WE NEED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA OUR
CHILDREN MUST COME FIRST AND
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IDOL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO SENT REPORTERS.
THE NUMBER THAT I'D LIKE TO
COMMEND THE SENATOR FROM IRVINE
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD.
NORMALLY AT ONE OF THE BEDROCK
BEDROCK PRINCIPLES THEIR LEGAL
SYSTEM IS THE- CONSTITUTIONALLY
PROTECTED RIGHT TO CONFRONT AN
ACCUSER. THAT'S NOT THE
SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES IN
WITH CHILDREN. AND I'VE SEEN
FIRST HAND- WHAT IT'S LIKE WHEN
CHILDREN ARE PITTED AGAINST
PARENTS IN A CUSTODY BATTLE OR
THEY'RE HAVING TO CONFRONT
NDER DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
THOSE THAT- CAN INTIMIDATE AND
LEAVE LONG LASTING IMPRESSIONS-
ON THOSE WHO WERE WITHIN
SUBJECTED TO CROSS EXAMINATION.
IN A CUSTODY BATTLE. SO THIS IS
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT THAN OUR
TRADITIONAL NOTION OF. OUR
BEING ABLE TO CROSS EXAMINE
SOMEBODY ELSE AND THESE ARE
VERY UNIQUE AND VULNERABLE-
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT CHILDREN
FIND THEMSELVES IN. AND I AM
PROUD TO CO AUTHOR- THIS BILL
WITH THE CENTER FROM IRVINE
AND- THANK YOU FOR MOVING US
FORWARD AND CERTAINLY-
ENCOURAGE ALL OF US TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT SERMON YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO FOR
THOSE KIND WORDS AND FOR BEING
A CO AUTHOR I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN PARK.
FOR HER. INCREDIBLE STORIES AND
HER STRONG ADVOCACY FOR THE
SAFETY OF FAMILIES AND
CHILDREN. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTERMAN MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM EYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON THE
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SENATOR
NEWMAN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY THREE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN RELATIVE TO CASA
APPRECIATION DAY SENATOR NEWMAN.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESENTS
ANDERSON I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT S. U. R. FORTY THREE-
COMMEMORATING MAY TWENTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS CAST A
PREVIOUS DAY IN CALIFORNIA
COURT APPOINTED SPECIAL
ADVOCATES FOR CHILDREN
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS CASA
VOLUNTEERS PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN ADVOCATING FOR THE BEST
INTERESTS OF CHILDREN IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HAS ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN THE
VICTIMS OF ABUSE NEGLECT OR
HAVE BEEN ABANDONED IN MANY
CASES THESE CHILDREN ARE
VULNERABLE TO AN OVERBURDENED
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM CASA
VOLUNTEERS PLAY AN IMPORTANT
ROLE BY GETTING TO KNOW A
FOSTER CARE CHILD AND
ADVOCATING THE CHILD'S
PERSPECTIVE AND UNIQUE NEEDS TO
THE JUDGE. AND OTHERS IN THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. WITH THAT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE- IN SUPPORT OF S. U. R.
FORTY THREE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION I THINK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD- YOU
KNOW A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE
DIRECTOR OF KERN COUNTY CASA
PROGRAM WAS- MY WOMAN OF THE
YEAR. BECAUSE SHE WAS ABLE TO
MOBILIZE THOUSANDS OF
VOLUNTEERS TO HELP COURT
APPOINTED AND CHILDREN IN THE
SYSTEM IN WHAT THE OTHER SIDE
IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT SOMETIMES
IT'S THE ONLY THE CASA ADVOCATE
THAT HAS. AN ACCESS TO THE
JUDGE AND OTHER INDIVIDUALS TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE CHILD AND WHAT
IS BEST IN THE BEST INTEREST OF
THE CHILD AND THESE ARE
WONDERFUL VOLUNTEERS AND- IT'S
A WONDERFUL ORGANIZATION. THAT
EXIST I BELIEVE IN ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS AND I THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD
AND REQUEST AND I THOUGHT.
CENTER GROVE MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SATURDAY WHEN
YOU MAKE CLOTHES. I THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR THE VERY KIND
WORDS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE HANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN MADAM
SECRETARY- SKEWS ME MEMBERS.
THIS IS THE ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION. SEEING AND
HEARING THEN EYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE AND
ONE SEVENTY SIX SENATOR DORADO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL- PLEASE REPEAT THE BILL.
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY FOUR
BY SENATOR JOE RASO AN ACT
RELATING TO DETENTION
FACILITIES SENATOR RAZA THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THREE
THREE FOUR WILL REQUIRE FOR
PROFIT PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES TO ADHERE TO ALL
APPROPRIATE STATE AND LOCAL
HEALTH SAFETY FIRE AND JAIL
STANDARDS ME TO MAINTAIN
SPECIFIC INSURANCE COVERAGES.
AND SUBMIT REPORTS THE
INSURANCE PROVIDER AND THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER'S OFFICE
AND TERMINATED FACILITIES
INSURANCE COVERAGE IF THESE
REQUIREMENTS ARE NOT MET. FOR
PROFIT DETENTION FACILITIES
HAVE A HISTORY OF POOR POOR
CONDITIONS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
A. B. THIRTY TWO WAS FINE TO
ADDRESS CONDITIONS IN PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT FACILITIES- A
PROHIBITED NEW CONTRACTS FOR
THE OPERATION OF PRIVATE
FACILITIES. AND THE GRADUAL
PHASING OUT OF THE- FACILITIES
BUT UNFORTUNATELY. MANY
COMPANIES RUSH TO ENTER INTO
CONTRACTS TO CIRCUMVENT THAT
LAW. THERE ARE NUMEROUS REPORTS
DETAILING CONDITIONS AND
ABUSIVE TREATMENT IN THESE
FACILITIES INCLUDING THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY. FORD FINDING
THAT THE ADELANTO DETENTION
FACILITY FAILED TO MEET MANY OF
THE GOVERNMENT'S OWN STANDARDS
AND THAT THE OPERATORS DID NOT
ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS DESPITE
REPEATED WARNINGS. THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL APPLY
EQUALLY TO FOR PROFIT
FACILITIES ENGAGED IN CIVIL AND
CRIMINAL DETENTION WE EXPECT
ALL FACILITIES OPERATE IN THE
STATE TO IT HERE TO THE SAME
STANDARDS AND GUIDELINES. IT
ENSURES THAT THE PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT PRISONS AND DETENTION
FACILITIES MAINTAIN INSURANCE
AS A FINAL A FIVE A FINANCIAL
MOTIVATION TO HERE TO THE LOCAL
AND STATE STANDARDS DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND. COLLEAGUES
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS-
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS. BABIES BACKER. HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD BYE COULD BUY A
FIVE CORTEZ HE I DALLY NO DODD
HI DURAZO HI ADNAN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. CLAVA I LIVE MY OWN. I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MEN.
FIVE NEWMAN FIVE NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF BOTH. NO PAN I FORTUNE
TINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BERG I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL.
NO SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SENTENCE IN THE EIGHT
CENTER CABALLERO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX BY SENATOR KERR BIO AN
ACT RELATING TO LAND USE
SYNDERGAARD BIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY 2% S. B.
EIGHT THE NEIGHBORHOOD HOMES
ACT. IN ORDER TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA'S FAMILIES THE
STATE MUST INCREASE HOUSING
PRODUCTION GET THE LACK OF
AVAILABLE LAND FOR RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT CONTINUES TO BE A
BARRIER TO BUILD. THIS ADAPTIVE
REUSE BUILT WILL SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION CENTER RIGHT OVER
YOUR- MANTA REVIEW FOR A SECOND
YOU SAID SENATE SENATE BILL
EIGHT IS WE THINK IT'S S. B.
SIX. YES VERY GOOD WE JUST WANT
TO BE CLEAR SORRY INTERRUPT
PLEASE PROCEED NO PROBLEM. THIS
ADDS ADAPTIVE REUSE BILL WILL
SPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION BY
AUTHORIZING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENT ON EXISTING LOTS
CURRENTLY ZONED FOR COMMERCIAL
OFFICE AND RETAIL USE SUCH AS
STRIP MALLS OR LARGE MALLS AND
BIG BOX RETAIL SPACES. MOST
SIMPLY SB SIX WILL SPUR HOUSING
PRODUCTION BY ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO APPROVE
RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT ON COMMERCIALLY
ZONED RETAIL OR OFFICE SPACE BY
UTILIZING AN EXPEDITED PROCESS.
REQUIRING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
MEET OR EXCEED THE DENSITY
DEEMED APPROPRIATE TO
ACCOMMODATE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
SUCH AS APARTMENTS TOWN HOMES
AND CONDOMINIUMS AND PROVIDES
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL DECISION
MAKING BY SUBJECTING
DEVELOPMENT TO LOCAL PLANNING
PARKING AND DESIGN ORDINANCES.
WE HAVE SEEN A SHIFT IN
CONSUMER PREFERENCES OVER TIME
WHICH HAS LEFT MANY COMMUNITIES
WITH STRIP MALLS AND MALLS WITH
MAJOR TENANT BIGOTS VACANCIES
WHICH CONTRIBUTE TO THE DECLINE
OF THE RETAIL CENTER INCREASING-BLIGHT. VANDALISM AND DECLINING
SALES TAX REVENUES IN MY RURAL
DISTRICT THESE RETAILERS ARE
OUR MAJOR TENANTS AND I EXPECT
TO SEE MANY MORE RETAILERS
LEAVE AS THE ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO STRUGGLE. THESE UNDER
UTILIZED IN BAKING VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACES ARE ALONG
MAJOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
ROUTES AND CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT
ACREAGE AVAILABLE TO DEVELOP
FOR MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT TO
CREATE WALKABLE LIVE WORK PLAY
VILLAGES. THIS CONCEPT WILL
ALSO HELP REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLE TRIPS ARE
ERRANDS BY LOOK LOCATING
SERVICES WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE. WITH NO COST TO THE
STATE SB SIX WILL INCENTIVIZE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT
IMPACTING SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS BY GIVING
LANDOWNERS AND DEVELOPERS A WAY
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
HOUSING. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU CENTER
CONWAY- MEMBERS DISCUSSION. AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY'S
HIGH RISE ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FROM
SELENA'S FIRMING IN THIS
FORWARD. HI THIS IS A BILL THAT
CAME OUT OF OUR SENATE HOUSING
WORKING GROUP AND I HAVE TO
SAY. THAT THIS BILL WAS BUILT
BASED ON THOUGHTFUL MESS
BROUGHT ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO THE
TABLE IT REALLY WAS A CONSENSUS
BILL AND I ALSO. KNOW AS A
LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER PREVIOUS A
LOCAL COUNCIL MEMBER HOW
DESPERATELY NEED AT THIS BILL
IS AND WE ALREADY KNOW WE'RE
SUFFERING FROM A HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
REALLY CAUSING CRISIS. FOR
FAMILIES TO GO UP AND THIS IS
JUST IN MY OPINION A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE AND WITH THAT I
ALSO ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SO TO COVER WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. BASICS
BACKER I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I
HAVE A HI CORTESE HI DALLY. DOT
HI TORONTO I EGGMAN I BELIEVE
HER. GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WISH SO. HI HER
TADO I JONES I CAN LONGER. I
LAYERED. LLEVA HI LYNN MON I
REQUIRE. I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN FIVE NELSON. A SHOW OF
BOTH HI PAM. HI PERSON TINA I
BROUGHT I RUBIO. I SKINNER FIVE
STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT I
LIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WILL
LOOK. THEN REMOVED CALL WE WERE
REMOVING THE FILE AND ONE
EIGHTY TWO SENATOR CABALLERO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR KERR BIO AN ACT RELATED
TO COMMUNICATIONS CENTER
CABALLERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. WISH TO PRESENT S.
B. TWENTY EIGHT THE RURAL
BROADBAND IN DIFFA REFORM ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT DOES TWO THINGS
FIRST IT PUT STATE ASSETS TO
WORK IN THE DEPLOYMENT OF
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY CALTRANS THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
OTHER RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES
TO INVENTORY STATE RESOURCES.
THAT CAN BE PUT MADE AVAILABLE
FOR BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE AT
MINIMUM SPEEDS OF A HUNDRED
MEGABITS PER SECOND DOWNLOAD
SPEEDS. S. B. TWENTY EIGHT
TAKES A BROAD VIEW OF STATE
RESOURCES INCLUDING REAL
PROPERTY THAT COULD BE USED TO
CITE BROADBAND EQUIPMENT RIGHTS
OF WAYS IT COULD BE USED FOR
ROUTING FIBER AND EVEN WIRELESS
SPECTRUM THAT COULD BE USED FOR
BANDWIDTH CAPACITY. S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT CREATES TEMPLATE
LICENSING AGREEMENT SO THAT THE
STATE CAN READILY CONTRIBUTE
THESE RESOURCES TO BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE. SECONDLY AS B.
TWENTY EIGHT AMENDS FOR THE
FIRST TIME THE STATUTE CALLED
THE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE
VIDEO COMPETITION ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND SIX OR DEFER. DEFER
PROVIDES CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS COMPANIES
WITH THE STATE WIDE TEN YEAR
LONG FRANCHISE LICENSE TO
DEPLOY DIGITAL VIDEO SERVICES.
SINCE THEY'VE GOT PAST THE
DIGITAL VIDEO PAY TV BUSINESS
ACCOMPLISH COMPLETE MARK MARKET
SATURATION MEANING PAY TV
SERVICES ARE AS UBIQUITOUS AS
ENERGY AND WATER UTILITIES
NEARLY A COMMODITY IN THEIR
SCALE. DIFFICULT FRANCHISEES
HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO LOW INCOME
BUILD OUT REQUIREMENTS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND FIVE I'M GONNA SAY
THAT AGAIN THEY HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO LOW INCOME BUILD OUT
REQUIREMENTS SINCE TWO THOUSAND
AND FIVE AND THE C. P. U. C.
DOES NOT RECEIVE SUFFICIENT
SELF REPORTED DATA. FROM THE
LICENSEES TO KNOW IF THOSE
RESIDENTS ARE RECEIVING
SERVICES IN A NON
DISCRIMINATORY MANNER NOW I
KNOW THAT YOU HVE BEEN MADE
AWARE. ABOUT THE LACK OF
SERVICES AND THE LACK OF HIGH
SPEED IN MANY OF OUR POOREST
COMMUNITIES AND IT'S NO
SURPRISE BECAUSE. THIS HAS BEEN
GOING ON SINCE. THE INTERNET
WAS FIRST THE PLANNED AND
ROLLED OUT WHY BECAUSE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO MAKE MONEY OFF OF
THOSE RESIDENTS AND SO AS A
CONSEQUENCE THE COMPANIES HAVE
CHERRY PICKED AND IT MADE- THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THE TO
THE COMMUNITIES IT CAN AFFORD
TO PAY FOR IT AND IF THERE'S
ONE THING THAT THIS DID THIS
PANDEMIC TAUGHT US IT'S THAT
THIS IN EQUITABLE SYSTEM. OF
INTERNET. AVAILABILITY HAS
REALLY HURT OUR FAMILIES HAVE
IT HAS HURT OUR BUSINESSES AND
HAS HURT- CHILDREN IN
PARTICULAR. GAINING S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT REFORMS DITKA IT
REQUIRES GRANULAR DATA BE
REPORTED TO THE C. P. U. C. SO
THAT FINALLY THE STATE WILL
HAVE AN ACCURATE ACCOUNTING OF
THE GAPS GAINING THIS ACCURATE
NETWORK MAP IS CRITICAL FOR
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT THIS DATA
THE CPUC CANNOT READILY
DETERMINE IF A LICENSE SHOULD
BE RENEWED FOR AN ADDITIONAL
TERM OF TEN YEARS AND RENEWING
A STATEWIDE LICENSE FOR THAT
LENGTHY PERIOD OF TIME WITHOUT
THIS DATA IS NOT IN THE PUBLIC
INTEREST PRIOR TO DAVE KA
FRANCHISE HOLDERS HAD TO
NEGOTIATE WITH EACH LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE GAME SUBSCRIBER
ACCESS IN A SERVICE TERRITORY.
AND DIFFICULT REMOVED LOCAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES FROM THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AND I
REMEMBER BECAUSE AS A MAYOR
WE'VE NEGOTIATED THESE DEALS
FOR MANY MANY YEARS UNTIL THE
STATE CREATED A STATEWIDE
FRANCHISE AND TOOK US AWAY FROM
THE TABLE S. B. TWENTY IT
REQUIRES THE CPUC TO CONSULT
WITH THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WITH
IN THE FRANCHISE FRANCHISEES
SERVICE TERRITORY RESTORING
SOME LOCAL NEGOTIATING POWERS
TO CITIES AND COUNTIES WITHOUT
IMMEDIATELY SHIFTING THE COST
AND COMPLEXITY OF NEGOTIATING
THE FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS BACK
TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. I
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
MEASURE BIG CENTRE COVER-
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT JUST A QUESTION
FOR OUR THE AUTHOR IF SHE'S
COMING OR WE TAKE A QUESTION
YES PLEASE PROCEED. TO YOUR
FARM WE RECEIVED INFORMATION
THAT THIS VIOLATES FEDERAL LAW
IT'S HARD ON A SHORT NOTICE
LIKE THIS TO CLARIFY THAT- CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THAT SO WE HAVE
SOME CLARIFICATION IF WE ARE.
ASKING C. P. U. C. TO DO
SOMETHING THAT IS BASICALLY
I'M- NOT IN A- CONCERT WITH
WHAT FEDERAL LAW SAYS ABOUT
THIS WHOLE ARENA. THANK YOU
OPERATOR YES MA'AM MADAM.
PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR THAT
pCOM COMPANIES WOULD WOULD LIKE
YOU TO BELIEVE THAT- THAT THIS
IS A VIOLATION OF FEDERAL LAW
AND IT IT IS NOT. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS VERILY VERY
CLEARLY GIVEN TO THE STATES. B.
THE RIGHT AND THE
RESPONSIBILITY. TO REGULATE THE
CABLE INDUSTRY AND THESE
COMPANIES HAVE WRAPPED THE
CABLE INDUSTRY TOGETHER IN A
PACKAGE WITH THEIR INTERNET
SERVICES AS WELL AS THEIR-
THEIR THEIR- PHONE SERVICES AND
WHEN THEY DO THAT THEN THEY
CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE ONE GOES
THE OTHER GOES WE HAVE THE
RIGHT. TO REGULATE CABLE AND
THAT'S WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL DELL DEALS WITH THIS CABLE.
AND SO THERE IS NO FRIEND OF
FEDERAL PREEMPTION FOR CABLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT IS A IN THE
INFORMATION THAT I READ THAT'S
LITTLE OF CONCERNING I DID SO
THE BETTER THINK I GONNA LAY
UNTIL I GET A MORE. CLEAR ON
SIDING WHICH LOOKS LIKE IT
COMES FROM. LAW THAT REGULATES
CPUC AND WHAT THEY CAN DO WITH
BROADBAND THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND OBVIOUSLY- IT HAS A NOBLE
CAUSE THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE CENTER
COVERING MY CLOTHES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MATTER PRESIDENT I
LET ME JUST ADD TO- TO THAT- TO
THE RESPONSE AT ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT YOU'RE IMPORTANT TO
ME IS MAKE SURE THAT- THAT. I'M
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH ALL
THE ENTITIES AND INCLUDING ALL
OF THE- TELECOM COMPANIES AS
WELL AS THE C. P. U. C. I'M IN
MAKING SURE THAT THIS VERY.
CAREFULLY IS CRAFTED SO THAT WE
DON'T RUN INTO A FEDERAL
PREEMPTION PROBLEM AND- AND
QUITE FRANKLY A NUMBER OF OTHER
STATES ARE WAY AHEAD OF US IN
THIS AREA. STATE OF NEW YORK
HAS BEEN. DOING A VERY VERY
SIMILAR PROGRAM FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND THEY HAVE. UP TO MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THEY HAVE-
ACHIEVE THE KIND OF A QUALITY
IN THEIR- DEPLOYMENT OF A VISA
SERVICES. THAT WE ARE SERIOUSLY
LACKING SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CENTER COVER GIRL MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS
BASED. BACKER. FIVE FOUR JUST I
BRADFORD I KERR BIO HI CORTESE
I DALLY. DODD HI DURAZO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER HI GOOD SOLID
HIGH GROWTH HIGH HURTS BERG HI
WITH SO. I HER TADO. HI JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED. LLEVA I
LIVE MY OWN FIVE MORE WIRE I
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN I
NELSON HI A TRAIL OF BOTH I PAN.
I FORTUNE TINO I ROCKED HI
RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN. I AM
BERG HI WAIT HOW SKI I WINNER I
WILL. SENATOR MOVED TO CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY EIGHT SENATOR
SKINNER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SIXTY FIVE BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO MATERNAL CARE AND SERVICES
SANDERS CAN. YES THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT PULLING UP MY QUICK SO.
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP SIXTY FIVE AIMS TO
ELIMINATE THE DISPARITIES IN
MATERNAL AND INFANT DEATH RATES
WHICH ARE HIGHER IN THE US THAN
THEY SHOULD BE BUT IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE FOR BLACK AND INDIGENOUS
MOTHERS AND BABIES. SERVICE B.
SIXTY FIVE MAKES PERMANENT THE
PREGNANCY MORTALITY REVIEW
BOARD REQUIRES BETTER DATA
COLLECTION ON MATERNAL AND
BIRTH OUTCOMES EXTENDS MEDIC
OUT UP TO A YEAR AFTER GIVING
BIRTH AND PROVIDES MEDICAL
COVERAGE FOR DOULAS IN
MIDWIFERY CARE. PROVIDES THOSE
ON CAL WORKS HIGHER MONTHLY
STIPENDS AND AN OPTIONAL WORK
REQUIREMENTS DURING PREGNANCY
AND FINALLY ESTABLISHES A THREE
YEAR PILOT WORK ANY COUNTY THAT
CHOOSES TO PARTICIPATE CAN
OFFER A GUARANTEED INCOME TO
LOW INCOME PREGNANT INDIVIDUALS
AND NEW PARENTS AND WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER SCANNER MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
GROVE. PRESIDENT YOU KNOW WHEN
THE AUTHOR BROUGHT THIS
BUILDING UP BEFORE US AND
HEALTH COMMITTEE DIDN'T HAVE
THE GUARANTEED INCOME PORTION
IN IT FOR A THOUSAND DOLLARS A
MONTH. AND I THOUGHT THAT- WHAT
SHE WAS OFFERING FOR CAL WORKS
TO HELP BENEFIT THEM TO-
INDIVIDUALS TO KEEP THEIR BABY
IN AND TAKE CARE OF THEIR BABY
WAS- GOOD BEFORE THE AMENDMENT
WAS TAKEN FOR GUARANTEED INCOME
SO- ALTHOUGH I SUPPORTED THE
BILL OF HEALTH COMMITTEE AFTER
RESPECTIVELY- OPPOSE THE BILL
NOW. BECAUSE A GUARANTEED
INCOME FOR A CERTAIN PERIOD OF
TIME IS JUST NOT WHAT I THINK
IS A- IS A CONSERVATIVE VALUE
THAT- INDIVIDUAL SHOULD TAKE I
THINK THAT THEY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO THE WORK PROGRAM AND-
THEY SHOULD STILL BE ABLE TO
APPLY AND WORK FOR- AND WORK IF
WORK IS AVAILABLE TO THEM. AND
ALSO AND HELP THEM GET OFF OF A
CALIFORNIA SUBSISTENCE INSTEAD
OF KEEPING THEM ON IT
GUARANTEED. SIX GROVE MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SANDERS
CAN REMAIN CLOSE. THANK YOU-
THE- MEMBERS JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT THE GUARANTEED
INCOME IS A PILOT PROGRAM ONLY.
AND IS- OPTIONAL FOR CARE BUT
ANY COUNTY CAN'T PARTICIPATE
WHO CHOOSES. BUT IS OPTIONAL
AND IS FOR VERY LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. THEY DID THAT
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA. I AT KINS
BAIT. BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD HI COULD BUY A FIVE OR
TEN THIRTY FIVE DALLY. DODD
FIVE TORONTO FIVE EGGMAN FIVE
GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG HI WAY SO. HI HER
TADO FIVE JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. LLEVA HI THE MON HI
WIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I
NEWMAN I NIELSEN. NO A SHOW A
BOOK. PAM HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE ASKING
FIVE WINNER. I WILL. SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE AND ONE NINETY SENATOR
DODD. BEN SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL NINETY NINE BY
SENATOR DODD AND ACTUALLY INTO
ENERGY CENTER DOT THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SP NINETY
NINE ESTABLISHES A NEW
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND GRANT
PROGRAM AT THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OF DEVELOPING
CLEAN ENERGY RESILIENCE PLANS
IN COLLABORATIONS WITH
UTILITIES PRIORITIZING ENHANCE
RESILIENCE FOR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES THE INCREASING
FREQUENCY OF NATURAL DISASTERS
AND UTILITY ISSUES OF.
PROACTIVE POWER SAFETY SHUT
OFFS IMPOSE ENORMOUS COSTS ON
CALIFORNIA IT PROMPTED MANY
HOMEOWNERS BUSINESSES AND
UTILITIES TO RUSH TO PURCHASE
HIGHLY POLLUTING BACKUP
GENERATORS THERE IS A BETTER
ALTERNATIVE THAT ENHANCES
ENERGY RESILIENCE USING
DECENTRALIZED LOCALLY PRODUCED
CLEAN ENERGY OUR STATE'S
ELECTRIC DISTRIBUTION UTILITIES
HAVE BEEN WORKING- TO ENHANCE
RESILIENCE THROUGH OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO THEM BUT THE THEY
DO NOT CONTROL LOCAL PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE ROADS AND
PARKING LOTS OF MUNICIPAL
FACILITIES. PLACES WHERE NEW
DISTRIBUTED ENERGY RESOURCES
COULD BE STRATEGICALLY LOCATED
BECAUSE ENERGY RESILIENCE IS
INHERENTLY LOCAL BUILDING A
MORE RESILIENT SYSTEM WILL
REQUIRE THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WORK COLLABORATIVELY WITH
DISTRIBUTION UTILITIES TO PLAN
IN SIGHT DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES YES B. NINETY NINE
PROVIDES LOCAL GOVERNMENT WITH
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IS
ASSISTANCE USE ME AND RESOURCES
TO DETERMINE HOW AND WHERE TO
SITE NEW ENERGY RESILIENCE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN COORDINATION
WITH THE LOCAL DISTRIBUTION
UTILITY. SP NINETY NINE WILL
FOSTER COLLABORATION BETWEEN
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS COMMUNITY
STAKEHOLDERS AND PUBLIC
UTILITIES TO DEVELOP RESILIENCY
PLANS TO- THAT ARE CRITICAL TO
MEET OUR ENERGY AND CLIMATE
GOALS RESPECTIVELY FOR I. THINK
YOU SAID OR DONE MEMBERS
DISCUSSION. OR DEBATE SENATOR
STERN. THANK PRESIDENT- MEMBERS
I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT IS
MEASURED AS WANTED TO- AT A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PERSPECTIVE
WE'VE HAD HUNDREDS OF HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LEFT IN
THE DARK FROM THESE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS AND- WE KNOW THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. OFTEN DON'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES AND- ACTING IN
THIS EARLY TO NAVIGATE THE
COMPLEX STATEWIDE PROGRAMS WE%
DO HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
BOTH IN THIS BUDGET IN N. P. U.
C. PROGRAM SO HOPEFULLY WE GET
THIS MEASURE DONE AND- KEEP THE
LIGHTS ON GOING THROUGH THIS
NEXT WILDFIRE SEASON
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU CENTER CERN
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE.
SENATOR RICHARD TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS. BASED I BACKER I
PORGES. BRADFORD I HAVE A
HYPERTENSIVE. I DALLY HI TODD
HI THERE ARE SO HI ADNAN HI
LASER FIVE TEN DOLLARS I GROVE.
FIVE HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I
HER TADO. HI JONES I CAN LONGER
I LAYERED. LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S I MEN I
NEWMAN. I NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF
BOTH. HI PAM FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS. FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN I AM BERG I LIKE ASKING
FIVE WINNER I WELL I. CENTER
MUSICAL MEMBERS REMOVED THE
FILE AND ONE NINETY SEVEN
SENATOR NEWMAN MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
SIXTY SIX BY SENATOR NEWMAN AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE PARKS
SENATOR NEWMAN AT THE HUMANA
PRESENCE ANDERS S. B. TWO SIX
SIX WILL DIRECT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO INCORPORATE
LANDED TO CHINO HILLS STATE
PARK THAT HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED
FOR ACQUISITION AND
PRESERVATION THROUGH LOCAL
CONSERVATION EFFORTS. AND FOR
WHICH FUNDING HAS BEEN
BILL THAT HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH
SIDES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
BASE I BACKER HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW HI
CORTESE I DALLY. I DON I
TORONTO I EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH HI HI
HURTS BERG HI WITH SO. I TIDO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOR I LIVE MON. I REQUIRE
HI MELINDA'S I MEN FIVE NEWMAN
I NIELSEN HI A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I FOURTEEN TO NO. I. ROSS
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN
HI I AM BERG FIVE WHAT KASKY
FIVE WINNER. I WELL I THIRTY
NINE THOSE ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO
FILE AN M. TWO ZERO ONE SENATOR
SKINNER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWO NINETY BY
SENATOR SKINNER AND ACTUALLY TO
HOUSING SENATOR SKINNER THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. MEMBERS OF THOSE OF
YOU WERE HERE LAST YEAR SO THIS
BILL WHEN YOU SUCCESSFULLY
PASSED IT AS DID THE ASSEMBLY
BUT IT. JUST MISSED OUR LAST
MINUTE CARD MIDNIGHT DEADLINE-
THAT LAST NIGHT A SESSION SO IN
OTHER WORDS WE DIDN'T GET A
CHANCE TO TAKE IT UP SO I'M
BRINGING IT BACK BECAUSE YOU'RE
ALL WERE SO ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT
IT LAST TIME. AND WHAT THIS
BILL DOES S. B. TWO NINETY
WHICH IS THE REINTRODUCTION OF
SP TEN EIGHTY FIVE IS IT
UPDATES OUR CALIFORNIA EXISTING
DENSITY BONUS LAW. AND WHAT IT
DOES IS IT RIGHT NOW THE
DENSITY BONUS LAW HAS NOT BEEN
ABLE TO BE APPLIED TO HOUSING
THAT IS BUILT FOR STUDENTS SO
IT ALLOWS THE GIVES A
DEFINITION OF WHAT STUDENT
HOUSING WOULD BE ALLOWABLE. AND
GIVE US AN INCENTIVE A DENSITY
BONUS NCENTIVE IF 20% OF THE
UNITS ENOUGH STUDENT HOUSING
PROJECT OUR DEDICATED FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS. IT ALSO%
CONFORMS OR DENSITY BONUS LAW
WITH ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS IN
OUR OTHER EXISTING IN SOME OF
OUR OTHER EXISTING HOUSING
LAWS. AND EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF FOR SALE PROJECTS
BEYOND COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS SO IT CAN INCLUDE
UNITS FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SCANNER.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING IN HERE NONE MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS
BASED. NO BACKER. HI FOR JUST
NO BRADFORD. I HAVE A HI
CORTESE HI DALLY. DOT HI
DERISIVE HI ADNAN HI BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG FIVE FIVE WITH SO. HI
FURTADO'S HI JONES NO CAN
LONGER. HI LAYERED. HI LLEVA HI
LYNN MON HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. MAN HI NEWMAN. HI
NIELSEN NO A CHOKE I PAN HI HI
FORTUNE TINO. HI ROSS HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER BYE I STERN I AM
BERG. I LIKE HOW SKI HI HI
WINNER. I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. ATKINS
DALLY. GROWTH MELINDA'S I WAS
THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ROOM
EACH FILE AND TWO FOURTEEN THAT
SET IT APART TINO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE REACH. SENATE
BILL FOUR FIFTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR FORTUNE TINO AN ACT
RELATING TO RETIREMENT. THE
REPORT DO YOU KNOW. THANK YOU-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND SENATORS SP
FOUR FIVE SEVEN WILL FURTHER
CALIFORNIA'S DIVEST IN FROM
TURKEY A COUNTRY WITH REPEATED
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATIONS. IN MY
DISTRICT MANY PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
IN THE CITY OF GLENDALE ARE
MEMBERS OF CAL STIRS IN CALPERS
AND THEIR DESCENDANTS OF THE
ARMENIAN GENOCIDE SURVIVORS
MOST OF THEM HAD TO RELIEVE.
THE INTERNATIONAL TRAUMA DURING
THE RECENT ARTSAKH WAR IN
TURKEY WHICH TURKEY WAS HEAVILY
INVOLVED THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT FUNDS WILL NOT BE INVESTED
IN THE SAME COUNTRY THAT THE
CONTINUES TO BE A THREAT. TO
THEIR FAMILIES IN ARMENIA
INVESTMENT FROM TURKISH BONDS
OVER THE GOVERNMENT'S DENIAL OF
THE ARMENIAN GENOCIDE WOULD
IMPOSE MUCH NEEDED ECONOMIC
CONSEQUENCES ON A REGIME THAT
CONTINUES TO ENGAGE IN POLICIES
THAT CONSTITUTE CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY. TURKEY SHOWED ACTIVE
MILITARY SUPPORT TO AZERBAIJAN
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ARTSAKH
WAR. DEEPENING INSTABILITY OF
THE REGION JUST THIS YEAR
TURKEY WITHDREW FROM THE
COUNCIL OF EUROPEAN CONVENTION
ON PREVENTING AND COMBATING
VIOLENCE AGAINST WOMEN AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BETTER KNOWN
AS THE ISTANBUL CONVENTION AND
IT CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
AZERBAIJAN'S REFUSAL. TO RETURN
PRISONERS OF WAR TO ARMENIA ON
TOP OF THE HUMANITARIAN ISSUES
THIS IS ALL SCHOOLS ALSO A
FISCAL ISSUE FOR OUR RETIREMENT
FUNDS SOCIAL INJUSTICE
POLITICAL INSTABILITY AND HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS CREATE AN
UNSTABLE MARKET THAT WE SHOULD
NOT BE INVESTING THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR CITY AND
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES. WE KNOW THAT
IT'S IN THAT IT IS POSSIBLE TO
DIVEST FROM TURKEY IN FACT
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
SUCCESSFULLY DIVESTITURE IN
TURKEY IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. I ASK YOU TO THINK
ABOUT ARMENIAN BROTHERS AND
SISTERS THE CALIFORNIA MEDIA
BROTHERS AND SISTERS ACROSS OUR
STATE HOW THEIR HARD EARNED
RETIREMENT FUNDS ARE CURRENTLY
BEING INVESTED IN A COUNTRY
THAT SLAUGHTER THEIR RELATIVES
DESTROY THEIR HISTORY. AND
CONTINUES TO DENY ITS ROLE IN
THESE ATROCITIES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN I. PHONE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PORTENT TINO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR BORCHERS. PRESIDENT I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE
ARMENIAN SENATE CAUCUS CHAIR'S
COMMENTS. NORMALLY I HAD
RESERVATIONS ABOUT USING
SOMETHING ARE AT OUR DISPOSAL
LIKE A RETIREMENT SYSTEM. TO
AFFECT INTERNATIONAL AFFAIRS.
BUT THIS IS AN ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT SITUATION IT'S
HISTORIC IT'S PERSONAL. AND AS
WE'VE SEEN WITH THE- ONGOING
HOSTILITIES. IN THE CAUCUSES
SPECIFICALLY IN ARTSAKH TURKEY
HAS NO INTEREST WHATSOEVER IN
CHANGING ITS SPOTS. IT HAS
SHOWN ITS NATURE IN A YOU'D BE
FOOLISH FOOLISH OF US NOT TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT HE BEHAVIOR IT
IS SHOWN IN LEARN FROM THAT. SO
IF THERE'S A WAY FOR CALIFORNIA
TO TAKE A MORE ASSERTIVE IN
TARGETED IN SURGICAL ROLE. IN
SENDING A MESSAGE TO THE
REPUBLIC OF TURKEY AND THE
ERDOGAN ADMINISTRATION. I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT IT IN
COLLEGE I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONSIDER THIS
EXCEPTION- ONE WORTH MAKING
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES THANK
YOU. I THINK YOU SAID REPORTERS
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEN
CENTER FOURTEEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN IPHONE. MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS BASED. HI
BECKER- HI. I COME BY OTHER
HIGH COURTS HOUSING. DALLY I
DOT. HI TORONTO. BY ADMIN HI
GLAZER HI HI CONDOLENCE. GROVE
HI HERTZBERG HI WITH SO HI HER
TADO BY JONES I CAN LONGER I
LAYERED HI LABOUR. THE MON HI
WIREHI MELINDA'S I MAN I
NEWMAN. NIELSEN FIVE A SHOW
BOTH I CAN. I FORTUNE TINO HI
ROTH. RUBIO FIVE SKINNER FIVE
STERN HI NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI
WHAT HAS HE- WINNER. FIVE WELL
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALAN I ADKINS. CORTESE.
GONZALEZ I. LAVER NEWMAN. ROTH
I BY CASCADE. FIVE THIRTY FIVE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING ON TO FILE
AN M. TWO TWENTY SENATOR
SKINNER MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
ACTUALLY DUE TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SANDERS CAN. WORKS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SERVE THINK MANY OF US
HAVE LOCAL PHARMACIES THAT
WE'VE BEEN USING FOR YEARS TO
FILL OUR PRESCRIPTION THEY KNOW
OUR MEDICAL HISTORY THEY MAY
PROVIDE SERVICES THAT ANOTHER
PHARMACY DOESN'T- YEAH WE'VE
GOT WE'VE SEEN IN RECENT YEARS
A PRACTICE BY SOMETHING IS
KNOWN AS PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGERS. WHERE THEY HAVE SENT
US YOU KNOW WE HAVE OUR HEALTH
INSURANCE AND THEY'VE SENT US
LETTERS SAYING HEY YOU CAN NOW
ONLY GET YOUR PRESCRIPTION
FILLED AT A PHARMACY AXE. AND
WHAT SP FIVE TWENTY FOUR DOES
IS IF YOUR PREFERRED LOCAL
PHARMACY HAPPENS TO BE IN
NETWORK WITH THAT INSURANCE
COVERAGE THAT YOU HAVE THEN IT
PREVENTS THE PHARMACY BENEFIT
MANAGER FROM. BASICALLY TELLING
YOU THAT YOU CANNOT USE ANY
PHARMACY BUT THE ONE THAT THEY
HAVE DESIGNATED SO THE PHARMACY
BENEFIT MANAGER CAN STILL
PROVIDE YOU A DISCOUNT WITH
THEIR PREFERRED PHARMACY IF
THAT'S WHAT THEY CHOOSE THEY
JUST CAN'T PROHIBIT YOU FROM
USING THE IN NETWORK PHARMACY
THAT YOU CHOOSE TO- AND WITH
THAT. I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOOK
THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO
RISE- SOMEBODY WHO WORKED
DILIGENTLY- IN THE ASSEMBLY ON-
THE PBMS AND IF YOU'RE IN A
RURAL COMMUNITY AND YOU HAVE A-
FAMILY OWNED A PHARMACY WHICH
IS RARE- MOST OF THE PHARMACIES
HAVE BEEN PUSHED OUT BY. THE
CFPB MS IT MANAGEMENT SYSTEM SO
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORITY THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY. TO MAYBE HELP KEEP
SOME OF THOSE PRIVATE
BUSINESSES IN IN THE RURAL
AREAS SOME CASES THE ONLY
PHARMACY WITHIN IN IN MY CASE
FIFTY MILES OF MY HOME. SO-
URGENT I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR HOLLINGS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE CENTERS CARRY
MY CLOTHES- THANK YOU AND HOPE-
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT
KINS. BABIES HI BECKER I
PORCHES. BRADFORD I HAVE A HI
CORTESE I DALLY I DON FIVE
TORONTO I EGGMAN FIVE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HI WAY SO. HI FURTADO I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED HI LLEVA.
HI THE MON. I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S BY MEN I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN. I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH I
CAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. I STERN HI
NUMBER FIVE WHAT KASKY. FIVE
WINNER HI WELL I. PLEASE CALL
THE OF THE MEMBERS. ATKINS
GORGEOUS I. GLAZER GROVE HI I
WAS THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES AND MEMBERS IF
YOU WERE GOING TO HAVE A
PRIVATE DISCUSSION IF YOU CAN
TAKE IT OFF THE FLOOR IT'S A
LITTLE HARDER TRYING TO HEAR
PEOPLE CAST THEIR VOTE WE'RE
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO TWO
TWO SENATOR BACKER HE'S READY
MADAM SECRETARY. PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE NINETY SIX BY
SENATOR BACKER AN ACT RELATING
TO GREENHOUSE GASES SENATOR
BAKER. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS.
HEARING THE CONCRETE. IS THAT
THE MOST WIDELY USED BUILDING
HERE IN THE WORLD A RECENT
STUDY ESTIMATED ACCOUNTS FOR
HALF OF THE WEIGHT OF ALL
THINGS EVER MADE BY HUMANITY.
IT'S ALSO 7% OF THE WORLD'S
CARBON EMISSIONS. FORTUNATELY
THERE ARE TECHNOLOGIES NOW IN
PLACE TO HELP DECARBONISE THIS%
HARD TO DECARBONISE SECTOR. IN
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE ARE WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY TO GET TO CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. AND SO THIS IS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THESE
HARD TO DECARBONISE INDUSTRIES
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
BAKER MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS
BAIT. NO BACKER. YEAH I FOR
JUST NO BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE
OR TEN THIRTY. HI DALLY. NO DOT.
HI TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER
HI CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. NO
HERZBERG HI WAY SO. HI HER TADO
HI JONES. NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO MAN HI
NEWMAN HI NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF
BOTH. NO PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. I
ROTH FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER
FIVE STERN I AM BERG ALL RIGHT
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI I WINNER I
WILL. NO HIGHS THIRTY KNOWS
NINE THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
RUBY ON THE FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
FIVE SENATOR HUESO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY FOUR BY SENATOR
HUESO AN ACT RELATING TO THE
ENVIRONMENT SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU TO PRESIDENT SENATORS
SP SIX TWO FOUR SIX TO
ESTABLISH AND PROMOTE
ENVIRONMENTAL EQUITY IN OUTDOOR
ACCESS IS A GOAL GOAL FOR ALL
STATE AGENCIES AND DEPARTMENTS.
THAT MANAGE NATURAL RESOURCES
WE ALWAYS TALK ABOUT EQUITY IN
OUR BUDGET PROCESS AND WOULD
LIKE TO SEE IT MORE APPARENT IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. THROUGH THIS
BILL WE ARE SEEKING TO ACHIEVE
MEMBER MENTAL EQUITY AND
PROMOTE EQUITABLE ACCESS FOR
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT HAVE BEEN
LEFT WITH THE LEASE ACCESS TO
THE STATE'S NATURAL RESOURCES.
THAT ARE THE MOST VULNERABLE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS AND THERE
IS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR
WAY SOME MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT KINS. EIGHT FIVE
BACKER. HI FOR JUST FIVE
BRADFORD. I COULD A HI COURTESY
HI DALLY I DON. HI THERE ARE SO.
HI ADNAN I BELIEVE HER. HI
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH. HI
HURTS BERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED.
HI LLEVA HI HI THE MON I
REQUIRE. HI MELINDA'S. MAN HI
NEWMAN I NELSON. I A SHOW BOTH.
I PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI ROTH
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. FIVE
STERN I AM BERG I CAN SEE HI
WINNER I WILL HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
BELINDA'S. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE AND TWO
TWENTY EIGHT SENATOR NEWMAN MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SIXTY BY SENATOR
NEWMAN AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR NEWMAN. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP SIX SIX ZERO WILL
ELIMINATE A COMMON PRACTICE IN
THE GATHERING SIGNATURES FOR
BALLOT MEASURES WHICH
INCENTIVIZES THE WILLFUL
DECEPTION OF VOTERS THEREBY
SERVING. AS A NECESSARY IMPORT
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
SAFEGUARDING THE INTEGRITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM AND RECALL PROCESSES
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF A NUMBER
OF STATES WHOSE CONSTITUTIONS
EXPRESSLY PROVIDED CITIZENS
WITH TOOLS CAN WORK DIRECTLY
REDRESS ABUSES OF GOVERNMENT OR
MALFEASANCE BY PUBLIC
OFFICIALS. IN THE FORM OF THE
INITIATIVE THE REFERENDUM AND
THE RECALL THE ORIGINAL FRAMERS
OF THE INITIATIVE REFERENDUM
AND RECALL INTENDED THESE
PROCESSES AS POPULIST ACTIONS
OF LAST RESORT IN SO DOING THEY
DELIVER THE PROVIDED THAT IN
ORDER TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT
THE PROPONENTS OF ANY THESE
DIRECT TO THE VOTERS. PLEASE-BESIDES WOULD FIRST BE REQUIRED
TO GATHER A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF VOTER SIGNATURES TO VALIDATE
THE LEGITIMACY AND POPULAR
SUPPORT FOR SUCH AN ACTION.
OVER THE YEARS AND ESPECIALLY
IN RECENT DECADES HOWEVER
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT THAN
THE FRAMERS INTENDED HAS
TRANSPIRED THESE TOOLS OF
DIRECT DEMOCRACY HAVE BEEN
INCREASINGLY CO OPTED BY THE
VERY MONEYED INTERESTS THEY
WERE ORIGINALLY CREATED TO
OFFSET. SP SIX SIX ZERO
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
PROHIBITING THE PRACTICE OF
PAYING SIGNATURE GATHERERS ON A
PER SIGNATURE BASIS WHEN
COLLECTING SIGNATURES TO PLACE
A STATE OR LOCAL INITIATIVE
REFERENDUM A RECALL ON THE
BALLOT. THIS MEASURE WILL NOT
PROHIBIT PAYMENT FOR SIGNATURE
GATHERING THAT IS NOT BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES
OBTAINED CHANGER GATHERS CAN
STILL BE PAID ON AN HOURLY OR
SALARIED BASIS THIS GOOD
GOVERNMENT MEASURE WILL SERVE
TO STRENGTHEN A RECALL
REFERENDUM AND INITIAL
PROCESSES. BY ENSURING THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS ARE AWARE OF
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE SIGNING
AND I'M NOT BEING DECEIVED TO
OTHER STATES SUCH AS COLORADO
MONTANA AND OREGON HAVE ALREADY
EXAMINED THE ISSUES SURROUNDING
PAID SIGNATURE GATHERS AND
ADOPTED LEGISLATION PROHIBITING
PERSINGER BOUNTY PAYMENTS
REQUIRING INSTEAD THE PAYMENT
PROCEDURE GATHERING. MAY ONLY
BE MADE ON AN HOURLY OR
SALARIED BASIS IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA TO DO THE SAME OR
TOMORROW CHRISSY AND GOVERNMENT
WILL BE THE BEST FOR IT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU SENATR
NEWMAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. ARCHULETA
I AT KINS. BASED NO BACKER HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD I HAVE A-
CORTESE HI DALLY. NO DODD. HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN HI GLAZER. NO
GONZALEZ HIGH GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. I LLEVA HI THE MON I
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MAN FIVE
NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHOKE. A
SHOW BOTH NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH. HI RUBIO I
SKINNER HI STERN I AM BERG ALL
RIGHT HI WHAT KIND OF SKI I
WINNER I WILL. NO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN AT
KINS. BY ADAM. NO MELINDA'S NO.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN WINDOWS
ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE
AN M. TWO THIRTY ONE SENATOR
RUBIO AND SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR RUBIO AND ACTUALLY
DUE TO HOMELESSNESS SENATOR
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MAN LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT S. BE SIX
SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA IT WILL BE THE FIRST
STATE IN THE NATION TO FOCUS ON
UNIQUE NEEDS OF UNACCOMPANIED
WOMEN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. DESPITE MAKING UP
NEARLY ONE THIRD OF HOMELESS
ADULTS NATIONWIDE THERE ARE NO
PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON THE NEEDS
AND THEIR EXPERIENCES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ALSO NOTE THAT 80%
OF THIS GROUP REPORTED TRAUMA
OR ABUSE. AT THE FOR THE COST
OF THEIR HOMELESSNESS SO WHEN
PEOPLE USUALLY ASK VICTIMS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE YOU KNOW WHY
DIDN'T SHE LEAVE. THIS IS. PART
OF THE ANSWER. THEY DIDN'T
LEAVE BECAUSE SOMETIMES VICTIMS
WOMEN AND MEN ARE FACED WITH
THE DECISION TO EITHER CONTINUE
TO GET ASSAULTED OR END UP
HOMELESS ON THE STREET THAT'S
NOT A REAL CHOICE. SO TODAY
WERE HOPEFUL TO PASS THIS
MEASURE SO THAT WE CAN GATHER
THE NECESSARY DATA WE NEED. TO
CREATE LONG LASTING SUSTAINABLE
SOLUTIONS FOR THIS GROUP. AND
SO TODAY I ASKED RESPECTFULLY
FOR YOUR SUPPORT WHICH IS THE
ONLY COUNTY DELEGATION PARTY
BILL SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THEM MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN EYES THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON THE FILE AND
I'M TWO THIRTY SIX SENATOR
LAMONT. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN THIRTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR LYNN MON AN
ACT RELATING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID SYNDROME THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
SB SEVEN THIRTY SEVEN MODIFY
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT
OPPORTUNITY AND ACCESS PROGRAM
KNOWN AS KELSO I HAVE A
PERSONAL UNDERSTANDING ON HOW
CAL SOAP OPERATIVE MISSION
PRIOR TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE
I WORK FOR CAL SOAP IN MY
DISTRICT ASSISTING STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES ON HOW TO
ACHIEVE HIGHER EDUCATION. THIS
BILL UPDATES THE STATUTE TO
REFOCUS THE PROGRAM'S FUNCTIONS
TO SERVE AS A FINANCIAL AID
AWARENESS LITERACY AND
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THE CURRENT
GOVERNING SECTION OF KELSO HAS
NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE ITS
CREATION AND ITS MODERNIZATION
IS ESSENTIAL TO REFLECT THE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENTS TODAY THE
BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE
QUALIFYING PEOPLE CRITERIA IN
RECOGNITION OF THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION
CURRENTLY KELSO CONSIST OF
SIXTEEN REGIONAL PROJECTS
ADMINISTERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STUDENT AID COMMISSION. THE
COUNCIL PROJECTS HAVE A
STATUTORY MANDATE TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION BY
RAISING ACADEMIC ELIGIBILITY
UNTIL A LEGIBILITY OF
UNDERSERVED STUDENT POPULATIONS
I RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN I LOVE
THANK YOU SENATOR LAMONT.
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEM
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT
KINS BATES NO BECKER HI PORGES
NO BRADFORD I COME BY OTHER. I
PROTESTING I DALLY. NO DODD HI
TORONTO HI EGGMAN HI GLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HI GROSS NO
HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JONES NO CAN LONGER I
LAYERED. HI LLEVA FIVE THE MON.
I REQUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO MAN.
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHOKE I
PAN HI FORTUNE TINO. FIVE ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN HI
NUMBER ALL RIGHT I BY CASTING
FIVE WINNER. I WILL. PLEASE
CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS. ATKINS.
RUBIO I WILKE. FIVE THIRTY ONE
OH SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWO NINETY SENATOR LAYERED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOUR THIRTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR LAYERED AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY
REDEVELOPMENT CENTER LATER
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
THIS IS A DISTRICT BILL AND HAS
HAD NO NO VOTES IN THE PROCESS.
BASICALLY THE CITY OF
ATASCADERO MADE LOANS TO START
THE REDEVELOPMENT AGENCY WAS IN
THE PROCESS OF GETTING THEM
PAID BACK AND HASN'T HAD BEEN
COMPLETELY PAID BACK BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MET WITH
THE ITY AND SAYS THEY NEED
STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DO IT
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THOSE LONG
STATUTORILY. IT'S WIDELY
SUPPORTED LOCALLY IN THE
DISTRICT AS I SAID NO NO VOTES
I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE.
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEN
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I WAS
FORTY NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN CENTER ATKINS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE BY SENATOR
ATKINS AN ACT RELATED TO
COASTAL COASTAL RESOURCES
CENTER ACTIONS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES WE'VE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE DEVASTATING
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE FROM
DISASTERS LIKE MASSIVE
WILDFIRES WE'VE LOST HUNDREDS
OF LIVES C. NG PROPERTY
DESTROYED AND SUFFERED BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER COST TO
LONG PERIODS OF SEVERE DROUGHT
WHICH HAS AFFECTED THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO GROW FOOD. CLIMATE
CHANGE IS ALSO ACUTELY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA'S COASTED
MORE SUBTLE IN DAMAGING WAYS
THROUGH SEA LEVEL RISE. WARNING
TO THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE ARE LMAO CALIFORNIA
COULD EXPERIENCE C. LEVEL RISE
OF HALF A FOOT IN THE NEXT
DECADE IN UP TO SEVEN FEET BY
THE END OF THE CENTURY. IRIARTE
CONVINCED LIKE COASTAL STORMS
AND KING TIDES WERE ABLE FI
THESE EFFECTS. STATE GOVERNMENT
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE ONLY
IN THE VERY EARLY STAGES OF
PLANNING FOR AND ANTICIPATING
SEA LEVEL RISE. THE LONGER WE
WAIT THE MORE COSTLY THE DAMAGE
WILL BE. IN FACT THE ELLIE-
RECOMMENDS MORE FUNDING GREATER
STATE REGIONAL AND LOCAL
COLLABORATION. AND BETTER
INFORM PLANNING AND LAND USE
DECISIONS TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL
RISE. AND THAT IS THE HEART OF
THIS BILL. SB ONE ESTABLISHES A
STRUCTURE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. SPECIFICALLY
THE BILL REQUIRES NEW PLANNING
IMPLEMENTATION OF PUBLIC AGENCY
COORDINATION REQUIREMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE IMPACTS OF SEA
LEVEL RISE. FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN CALIFORNIA LAW. S. B. ONE
ALSO ESTABLISHES A NEW CROSS
GOVERNMENT COLLABORATIVE TO
INSURE THE IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL
RISE ARE ANTICIPATED. AND
ADDRESSED BEYOND SIMPLY
ENVIRONMENTAL DEPARTMENTS. BUT
ALSO BY OUR TRANSPORTATION AND
INFRASTRUCTURE AGENCIES.
FINALLY IT PROVIDES NEW FUNDING
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET FOR STATE
REGIONAL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO PLAN FOR AND MITIGATE FOR
SEA LEVEL RISE. IN ADDRESSING
SEA LEVEL RISE WE CANNOT FORGET
ABOUT ADDRESSING OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THAT'S WHY THIS BILL EXPANDS
THE EXISTING CAL EPA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE GRANT
PROGRAM TO ENSURE THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES MOST
IMPACTED FROM SEA LEVEL RISE.
HAVE A VOICE IN ACTIONS
GOVERNMENT TAKES TO ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGE. SEA LEVEL RISE IS A
PROBLEM I'VE SEEN IT TAKE ROOT
IN MY COMMUNITIES AND THOSE OF
MANY SENATORS ACROSS THE STATE
I NEED ONLY MENTIONIMPERIAL
BEACH WHICH IS HAD TO PLAN- HOW
TO DEAL WITH THE FLOODING EVERY
SINGLE YEAR. A NUMBER OF OTHER
COMMUNITIES AND MOST OF US KNOW
WE HAVE CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
ALONG THE COASTLINE FROM
WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANTS OR
PORTS WHO ARE GOING TO BE
IMPACTED- AIRPORTS ECCENTRIC.
SO S. B. ONE. IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIA TO TAKE A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESS SEA LEVEL RISE IN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE THE SUPPORT
AND WORK WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITIES. I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUILT. THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I BASE HI BECKER HI FOR
JUST. BRADFORD HI COME BY ADAM
HI CORTESE I DALLY. NO DODD HI
TORONTO HI ADNAN FIVE GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATES HIGH GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I WAS SO HI HER TADO
HI JONES. CAN LONGER I LAYERED
I LABOUR HI LYNN MON HI MCGUIRE
HI MELINDA'S. NO MAN HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN. OCHO VOGUE. NO TEN
FIVE FOURTEEN TINO I BROUGHT
FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER FIVE
STERN HI AMBERG HI LIKE HOW SKI
FIVE WINNER I WILL LOOK. HI
PLEASE CALL THE UPSET MEMBERS.
PORGES GROVE. JONES NO NIELSEN
NO HIGHS THIRTY THREE KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AFTER THAT
WILL BE LIFTING CALLS- ON MADAM
SECRETARY DOES HE WANT
EVERYTHING THEY WANT TO TAKE
OFF OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ALL RIGHT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ALL ITEMS ON THE
CALENDAR. SENATE BILL FIVE
SEVENTY AND SENATE BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SIX AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI HI
ARCHULETA HI AT KENS FIVE BATES
HI BECKER HI PORGES HI BRADFORD
I COME BY ADAM. HI CORTESE HI
DALLY I DON. HI TORONTO BY
ADMIN I GLAZER HI CONSOLIDATES
HIGH GROWTH I HEARD SPURRED HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO. I JONES I
CAN LONGER I LAYERED I LABOR HI
HI THE MON. HI MCGUIRE HI
MELINDA'S. FIVE MEN HI NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN. BY A SHOW OF BOTH.
HI PAN HI FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER FIVE
STERN I AM BERG HI WHAT KIND OF
SKI. HI WINNER I WELK HI GUYS
FORTINO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
ITEMS THAT ARE ON CALL WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTMENTS FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS I COME BY OTHER I EGGMAN
I MAN I ROTH I STERN HI HIGHS
FORTY NO ZERO THE APPOINTMENT
IS ADOPTED MEMBERS WE'RE NOW
MOVING TO SP THREE THREE. FOUR
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
AT KINS I BASE. NO GORGEOUS. NO
GLAZER. LAYERED HI FIVE THIRTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING THE FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT S. B. SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. PARDON
ME THIRTY FIVE THIRTY KNOWS
NINE NOT SURE WHAT I SAID BUT
IT WASN'T RIGHT S. B. SIX WELL
ITEM. ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. ATKINS
I BASE NO PORGES. GLAZER DALLY.
GROVE. LAYARD R. I. NIELSEN.
WELK. FIVE THIRTY TWO NOSE TO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO S. B.
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
UPSET MEMBERS. ATKINS HI BABES.
DALLY LAYERED HI MELINDA'S.
WILKE. FIVE THIRTY SIX ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FOLLOWED A ONE EIGHTY EIGHT S.
B. SIXTY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS I BATES
NO PORGES NO DALLY. LAYERED I A
TOTAL OF BOTH. WILKE. DALLY NO.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE NOSE SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING THE FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY S. B. NINETY
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AT KINS I. FOR JUST.
GORGEOUS I. LAYERED HI I WAS
FOURTEEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING
BACK TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
SENATOR MELINDA'S. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- SENATORS
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT I'M MAKING A MOTION TO
WITHDRAW AS C. R. FIVE FROM THE
SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE AND
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR SO
WE CAN HAVE A FULL AND VIGOROUS
DEBATE. THE SENATORS IT TOOK
THE TITANIC THREE HUNDRED
MINUTES TO SYNC. WE HAVE BEEN
IN THIS LOCKED DOWN FOR FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN DAYS.
SAID DURING THAT FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN DAYS WE'VE HAD
ABOUT TWENTY THOUSAND
BUSINESSES THINK. IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE HAD NUMEROUS. BAILEY'S
WHOSE PERSONAL FINANCES. HAVE
ALSO SUNKEN. IT IS TIME TO END
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY. AND
WREST CONTROL BACK FROM THE
GOVERNOR AND PUT IT BACK WHERE
IT BELONGS. OVER HALF OF
CALIFORNIANS. HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED EVERYONE WHO WANTS A
VACCNE CAN GET. ONE THE
GOVERNOR STATED HE IS ENDING
HIS OPENING THE STATE IN LESS
THAN A MONTH SO THERE IS NO
REASON TO CONTINUE WITH THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY. IT'S BEEN
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
DAYS I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS.
THANK YOU SENATOR MELINDA'S
SENATOR HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THE MAJORITY LEADER
ASKS FOR A NO VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU THE MAJORITY LEADER
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE SENATOR
MELINDA THIS IS ASKING FOR AN
I. VOTE BENHAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES I
BACKER. NO PORGES HI BRADFORD
NO COME BY ADAM NO CORTESE NO
DALLY. HI DODD. NO TORONTO. NO
AND EVEN. NO GLAZER. NO
GONZALEZ NO GROWTH HI HERTZBERG
NO WAY SO. NO HER TADO NO JONES
I CAN LONGER NO LAYERED NO
LLEVA NO THE MON NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELINDA'S I MEN NO NEWMAN NO
NIELSEN. I A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
NO FORTUNE TINO NO ROCK NO
RUBIO NOPE SKINNER NO STERN NO
AMBERG OKAY NO WAY CASKEY. NO
WINNER NO WILKE. I. FIVE NINE
KNOWS THIRTY ONE THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW FAILS MEMBERS WERE
STILL UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR CAFIERO FOR
WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE. MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D LIKE TO MOVE FILE
NUMBER ONE FIFTY EIGHT S. B.
FIFTY NINE TO THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU SO NOTED. ANYTHING
ELSE MEMBERS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SEEING NONE IF
THERE IS NO FURTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR ACTIONS THE DESK IS
CLEAR. MA'AM PRESENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH AND THIS YOU SHOULD
LISTEN TO BECAUSE IT IS OUT OF
THE ORDINARY OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR
WEDNESDAY MAY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AT NINE THIRTY AM SO
I THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT
BACK TO YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
ATKINS THE SENATE WILL E
ADJOURNED MEMBERS WE WILL
RECONVENE WEDNESDAY AT NINE
THIRTY EIGHT AM HAVE A GREAT
REST OF THE DAY.